Little Ricky wieder. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 163. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und jetzt ist es endlich soweit nach einer langen Durststrecke der kulturellen und gesellschaftlichen Gesamtdiskussion. Wir wollen uns ja heute mal ein bisschen wieder auf die Technik stürzen und mal ein wenig in die Seele blicken einer ganz besonderen Programmiererkultur, nämlich der Ruby-Welt. Ganz besonders, warum die ganz besonders ist, das wird glaube ich auch schnell klar werden. Auf jeden Fall erstmal Hallo sagen zu Martin, Martin Wöginger. Hallo. Ja, du bist das erste Mal dabei hier. Gut so, wir haben ja schon lange mal darüber geredet, das mal zu machen. Umso mehr freue ich mich, dass das geklappt hat. Ja, du bist ja auch schon so ein Altschul-Hacker, oder? Du bist auch schon eine Weile dabei.
Programmieren mache ich schon eine Weile, ja. Ich habe auch angefangen seit 12 Jahren. ZX81, Klassik, Basic, dann Assembler. Ja, das ging ganz eine Weile. Nach dem Abi halt Studium dazu verdient, so ein bisschen herumgehackt. C, C++, 96, dann mit Java angefangen. Und seit vier Jahren bin ich jetzt bei Ruby. Ich mache auch andere Sachen, wie iPhone-Entwicklung. Aber aktuell ist Ruby mein Hauptsteckenpferd und auch meine Liebe.
Und da fühlst du dich am wohlsten?
Da fühle ich mich am wohlsten. Das Programmieren macht am meisten Spaß.
Ja, Ruby ist ja so ein Phänomen. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht so sehr überhöhen, aber ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern, als Ruby so aufgeschlagen ist im Netz. Es ist ja immer so eine Sache, wenn so neue Programmiersprachen aufkommen. Die Welt hat schon viele neue Programmiersprachen gesehen, nicht viele haben verfangen. Ruby hat relativ schnell verfangen und hat so aus meiner Sicht eine ganz interessante Kultur mit sich mitgezogen. Ruby war dann ja auch zum richtigen Zeitpunkt da, um quasi fürs Web 2.0 gerüstet, so eine neue Generation von Webseiten auch mit sich zu führen. Siehst du das ähnlich?
Ruby gibt es ja schon eine Weile. Das ist ja auch 1995 gegründet worden, war aber zuerst hauptsächlich im japanischen Markt und gab es auch überhaupt keine englische Übersetzung. Erst, glaube ich, fünf Jahre später ist es dann im englischen Kontinent, amerikanischen Kontinent drüber geschwappt und mit dem Steckenpferd Rails explodiert. Wobei, meiner Meinung nach, ist es nicht Rails, sondern die Power von Rails ist ja die Programmiersprache Ruby. Und der pragmatische Ansatz, der dahinter steht, wie du schon sagst, auch diese ganzen Web 2.0-Sachen, dass man es schnell entwickeln kann, im Gegensatz zu Java, wo alles sehr kompliziert war, wo man konfigurieren musste, XML-Dateien konfigurieren musste, hier gilt der Ansatz, Convention over Configuration. Was das ausmacht, das müssen wir dann in die Tiefen der Programmiersprache noch gehen, dass ich hier mit Ruby Sachen geschenkt bekomme.
Da bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen bei der Geschichte. Also das Ganze kommt aus Japan. Wie heißt er noch gleich hier?
Kuhira Matsumoto, auch Mats genannt. Seine Intention war es ja, eine Programmiersprache zu schaffen, die den Programmierer Spaß macht.
Wobei das ja alle Programmierer von ihren Lieblingsprogrammiersprachen behaupten, dass dem so sei.
Ja, Chawa zum Beispiel ist eine typische Industriessprache.
Da habe ich aber auch schon ein paar Freunde gehabt, die das ganz toll fanden und da eine Menge Spaß hatten. Findet sich ja zu allem was.
Also er hat sich ein paar Sachen gedacht, das hat sich herausentwickelt aus seinen Lieblingssprachen. Lisp, Smalltalk, Ada und Eifel. Und eins der Prinzipien, die dahinterstecken, das stammt aus einem Buch, The Tower of Programming, ist es The Principle of the Least Surprise. Kann man am ersten übersetzen mit dem Prinzip der geringsten Überraschung. Das heißt, es programmiert sich alles so, wie man es sich am ersten erwarten würde. Klar muss man Syntax lernen, man muss lernen, wie die Sprache funktioniert, aber das waren auch meine ersten Erlebnisse mit Ruby. Man probiert aus und es funktioniert einfach. Es tut das, was man erwartet von der Sprache.
Da gibt es ja auch so verschiedene Kirchen. Zum Beispiel gibt es ja die There's Always One More Way to Do It-Kirche aus dem Perll-Lager, was dann, wie Kritiker behaupten, dann immer schnell zu Variet-Ondi-Software führt, die zwar der Programmierer dann einmal hingeschrieben hat, aber die danach niemand anderes und manchmal eben auch der Programmierer selbst nicht mehr lesen können, weil es einfach so kryptisch ist, beziehungsweise weil die Sprache einem eben so viele Stile erlaubt, so viele unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen erlaubt, wie man eben das eine tun kann versus der anderen Kirche, die sagt, es gibt für alles genau diesen einen goldenen Weg, wie das denn eigentlich zu sein hat und so führt man dann sozusagen auch zum homogenen Schriftbild, auch über mehrere Programmierer hinweg, was dann eben auch so die Erkennbarkeit, Lesbarkeit, Wiederverwendbarkeit von Code macht. Wo würdest du denn da Ruby einordnen?
Also man kann auch Ruby Code schreiben, der unleserlich ist. Es gibt auch in Ruby mehrere Wege, Dinge zu tun, aber der Code ist sehr kompakt gehalten. Das geht auch. Ruby basiert auf sehr einfachen Prinzipien. Es ist, Ruby Code ist so konzipiert, dass man theoretisch zumindest behaupten, dass die dem Macher von links nach rechts lesen kann, was er tut. Es gibt z.B. diesen Ausdruck, Five-Punk-Times-Putz-Drink-Hello. Das ist ein Ausdruck, den man lesen kann und gebruchte heißt das. Also, mit dem Sinn kann man es nicht mit Perl vergleichen. Es gibt zwar Ähnlichkeiten zu Perl, wie z.B. der eingebaute Regular-Expression-Engine.
Ruby ist aber auch so ein bisschen als, ich weiß nicht, ob es von Anfang an so gedacht war, aber es lässt sich auf jeden Fall auch als typische System-Administrationssprache unter Unix ganz gut einsetzen. Im Prinzip steht es ja erst mal direkt in der Konkurrenz mit Perl und Python, weil es ähnlich situiert ist, auch ähnliche Grundverhaltensmuster macht, das ist halt so interpretiert. Man kann da irgendwie so seinen Source-Code schreiben und dann kann man das gleich ausführen. Man muss das irgendwie nicht übersetzen. Das ist ja jetzt bei den anderen Sprachen mit Einschränkungen auch so. Also Python macht noch so Zwischencode und so weiter, aber man kann im Prinzip so direkt so vom Source-Code einfach so losmarschieren. Was war denn sozusagen, weißt du, was so die Kritik an den existierenden Systemen war? Die dann den Mats dazu geführt hat, das nochmal neu zu machen. Man hat es jetzt als Einfluss genannt. Lisp, Smalltalk, Ada Eifel. Davon haben wir hier Lisp schon mal behandelt. Das ist ja sozusagen die Mutter aller Programmiersprachen. Und die Lisp-Verfechter sagen ja auch, man hätte eigentlich nie weitere Features hinzufügen müssen. Es ist schon alles da. Bloß dann eben mit der anderen Konkurrenz, dass das ja kein Mensch lesen kann mit den ganzen Klammern. Was ist jetzt sozusagen der Ansatz gewesen beim Design, außer dem, was du jetzt schon genannt hast, so mit dem von links nach rechts Lesen? Also worauf wollt ihr hinaus? Was sollte es alles können?
Beziehungsweise, man kann jetzt von der Kritik an Pearl ausgehen, dass es hier metaphysische Sachen gibt, die man einfach wissen muss. Man muss Pearl lernen und hier kann man Ausdrücke schaffen, die nachher nicht mehr lesbar sind. Ein wichtiger Aspekt ist die Objektorientierung, die er sich von Smalltalk abgeschaut hat. Das ist so ein einfaches Prinzip. Vielleicht kommen wir später noch dazu, dass alles ein Objekt ist. Jede Methode ist ein Objekt, jede Zahl ist ein Objekt, selbst Neil ist ein Objekt. Und je einfacher die Prinzipien einer Sprache. Sind, desto einfacher ist sie zu verstehen, desto übertragbarer ist das Wissen, was man an der einen Stelle generiert, auf die anderen Stellen, die man noch nicht weiß.
Und was ist da konkret von Ada und Eifel noch der Einfluss? Kannst du das benennen? Also Eifel, da habe ich jetzt auch irgendwie keine rechte Erinnerung mehr. Das ist ja auch so eine dieser akademischen Ansätze, die ich habe mal Leute getroffen, die waren total euphorisch, was so Eifel betrifft. Das ist auch schon eine Weile her. Und bei Ada, weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau. Also das ist mir unklar. Aber du meinst, das sind sozusagen die Quellen, die da benannt wurden. Ich meine, das Smalltalk, denke ich, das sieht man auch so, wenn man sich so Ruby anschaut. Was ist jetzt drin in der Sprache? Was muss man wissen, um zu verstehen, wie Ruby tickt?
Zunächst einmal gibt es, wenn man von der Basis anfängt, die einfachen Kontrollstrukturen. Es gibt Schleifen, wie in vielen anderen Sprachen auch, Oberschleifen, Weilschleifen, Until. Es gibt konditionale Ausdrücke, if, else, when, Switch-Statements. Es gibt Methodendefinitionen. Es gibt ein Exception-Handling. Es gibt allerdings auch für diese Sachen, und da fängt schon jetzt die Schönheit der Sprache an, Kurzformen. Ich kann beim Exception-Handling zum Beispiel direkt hinter dem Ausdruck ein Rescue stellen. Das ist das, was Java kennt, Strike-Catch-Finally, heißt in Ruby Begin-Rescue-Ensure. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einen Ausdruck habe, File-Open, kann ich dahinter schreiben, Rescue. Wenn ich eine Zuweisung mache, File ist File-Open, Rescue, Default-File.
Das heißt, jetzt mach mal die Datei auf, und wenn alles super ist, dann mach einfach weiter. Wenn nicht, dann geht er in diese Rettungsmaßnahme hinein, in diesen Blog, der nur dann aufgerufen wird, wenn es fehlgeschlagen ist.
Man kann alles in eine Zeile schreiben. Das ist die Kurzform davon. Genauso kann man If-Statements...
Man muss nicht immer so lange Blöcke schreiben, wie man das häufig kennt?
Die Sprache ist insgesamt sehr kompakt. Das ist aber auch nur freiwillig und Geschmackssache, um die Lesigkeit zu erleichtern. Hinterausdrücke, z.B. ein If-Statement machen. Das heißt, mach nur irgendwas, wenn eine Bedienung erfüllt ist. In den meisten anderen Programmiensprachen, die ich kenne, kann ich das If-Statement immer nur davor stellen. Manchmal erleichtert es die Lesbarkeit, wenn man es von oben nach unten liest, wenn das If dahinter steht. Das ist aber nicht immer so. Das ist aber auch Geschmackssache.
Das hat wahrscheinlich auch etwas damit zu tun, wie die eigene Sprache so funktioniert. Also die eigene, die man selber spricht.
Ja, beziehungsweise auch vom Kontext ist das abhängig. Je nachdem, wie wichtig das ist, was hier geschieht. Es gibt auch den umgekehrten Ausdruck von If. Das nennt sich Anlass. Das ist einfach das If-Not. Ich mache Variablenzuweisungen, wenn das noch nicht erfüllt ist.
Das heißt, das Ziel ist eigentlich, dass man den Programmcode danach singen kann. Das ist ein neuer Singer, der sein Kindern abends zum Einschlafen vorlesen will. Wenn sie wirklich einschlafen, dann weiß man, dass der Code wirklich langweilig war.
Mensch, Papa war jetzt nichts Besonderes dabei.
Und was... Das ist ja auch ein Konfliktfeld mit Syntax und Syntax Sugar, wie man es nennt, Sachen einbauen, damit es kez aussieht, sag ich mal.
Es geht wirklich um die Kompaktheit. Es geht um den Programmcode von oben nach unten lesen und wissen, was er tut.
Und du meinst, das erfüllt Ruby an der Stelle auch? Gibt es auch keine Risiken und Nebenwirkungen?
Natürlich. Dazu kommen wir auch noch später. Die ganzen dynamischen Aspekte der Sprache.
Ich meine, konkret von diesem Syntax-Sugar. Ich meine, gerade mit diesem IF steht vorne. Oder sind wir jetzt wieder genau so bei diesen religiösen Basislagern? Man muss dann erst noch mal hinten gucken, ob da noch ein IF dran ist.
Natürlich, man kann es definitiv übertreiben. Das meine ich ja. Das ist auch Geschmackssache. Das ist dann auch Abschätzung. Wie wichtig ist jetzt dieser IF-Ausdruck? Oder wie wichtig ist es, zu wissen, dass dieser IF-Ausdruck dasteht? Oder wie wichtig ist es, zu wissen, dass dieser Ausdruck ausgeführt wird?
Und gibt es auch schon so ethische goldenen Regeln, die irgendwo an der Internetplakatwand geschlagen wurden? Das ist schwer eine Rede zu fassen. Du sollst nicht übertreiben mit dem Syntax-Sugar?
Das gilt generell.
Du hast gesagt, dynamisch. Das ist natürlich immer das goldene Stichwort, wenngleich auch eines der immer sehr schwer zu definierenden Bereiche. Was denn nun wirklich so dynamisch ist? Was ist denn dynamisch an Ruby? Es gibt ja mehr als eine Sache.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal vorher erwähnen, du hast ja schon gesagt, Ruby ist eine Skriptsprache. Das heißt, sie wird interpretiert. Das heißt, alles ist ausführbarer Code. Jede Klassendefinition, jede Methodendefinition ist ausführbarer Code. Wenn ich jetzt eine Methode definiere und ich definiere die gleiche Methode an späterer Stelle noch einmal, dann gilt die neue Definition der Methode und die alte sozusagen überschrieben. Wenn ich eine Klasse definiere, kann ich hier auch mit Operatoren und variablen Zuweisungen arbeiten. Ich kann hier Klassen variablen zuweisen.
Also sprich, Variablen sind insofern dynamisch, als dass sie zu jedem Zeitpunkt jeden beliebigen Typ von Daten annehmen können. Genau. Auf beliebige Typen verweisen können.
Das ist ja auch ein Grundelement der Sprache. Das ist dynamisch stipisiert. Das heißt, man definiert keine Typen. Variablen werden wie in PHP oder JavaScript einfach definiert. Und an spätere Stelle wird entschieden, wichtig ist nur das, was sie können. Das nennt man dann Duck-Typing, wird das genannt. Das heißt, wenn etwas so waschelt wie eine Ente oder so quakt wie eine Ente, dann ist es eine Ente. Es muss sich nur so verhalten. Ob ich jetzt ein Objekt habe, das von der Klasse ist oder von der anderen Klasse ist, an dem Zeitpunkt, wo eine bestimmte Methode ausgeführt wird, egal. Hauptsache, sie implementiert diese Methode. Wenn diese Methode nicht implementiert, das heißt, wenn das Method Dispatching die Methode in einer ganzen Klassenhierarchie nicht findet, dann gibt es auch noch eine Möglichkeit, das nennt sich MethodNotFound. Das ist ein Hook, der eingebaut ist, den man überschreiben kann, mit dem man dann dynamische Methoden definieren kann. Das ist auch schon ein wichtiges Grundelement der dynamischen Sprache. So kann ich abfangen, wenn eine Methode nicht definiert wird, und diese Methode dynamisch hinzufügen.
Wir müssen vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen aufrollen für die Leute, die jetzt noch nicht so richtig in diesem ganzen ObjectSpeak drin sind. Dieses Klassenmodell geht ja davon aus, dass man seine Daten innerhalb des Programms in so bestimmten Hierarchien strukturiert, ausgehend von ihren Eigenschaften und Verwandtschaften. Das heißt, man hat halt im Allgemeinen dieses, und wenn man das dann im Spezielleren nochmal etwas verfeinert hat, dann verwendet man Vererbung, um sozusagen das meiste aus dem, was man schon geschrieben hat, einfach zu übernehmen. Und man ändert dann eben das, was in dem Fall nochmal anders ist. Indem man zum Beispiel Methoden neu schreibt oder hinzufügt, die eben dann sozusagen der Ursprungstyp nicht hat. Das ist alles drin in Ruby. Das ist sozusagen das klassische Objektmodell. Das ist ja auch so diese Verwandtschaft zu Smalltalk an der Stelle, wo das ja schon recht früh Anfang der 70er-Jahre zelebriert wurde. Smalltalk ist ja so ein bisschen so eine der, weiß nicht, ist es sogar nicht sogar die Sprache, in der man eigentlich dieses Objektmodell im Wesentlichen zu verdanken hat. Ich denke, das war so eigentlich der Pionier an der Stelle. Und das wird dann hier eben auch relativ konkret übernommen.
Was es von Smalltalk hat, ist das Prinzip, dass alles ein Objekt ist und dass die Objekte dynamisch sind. Wenn man vielleicht einen Vergleich macht zu Java. Ich komme ja auch sehr von Java oder von den statischen objektorientierten Sprachen. Man spricht von der Ruby-Seite eher aus, dass das eher klassenorientierte Sprachen sind. Das heißt, ich habe Klassen, das ist ja sozusagen das Template des Objekts, wo ich meinen Verhalten in Form von Methoden und meinen Status in Form von Instanzvariablen definiere, vordefiniere. In Ruby ist es so, dass selbst diese Klassen in Wirklichkeit nur Objekte sind. Und ich kann auch von einem Objekt, von einem ganz basic Objekt, wenn ich schreibe ObjectNew, kann ich dynamische Methoden hinzufügen. Das heißt, ich kann jedes Objekt dynamisch soweit verändern, dass ich Instanzvariablen oder Methoden hinzufüge.
Also dynamisch zur Laufzeit. Das Programm läuft. Und während es läuft, kann es irgendwie neue Funktionalität hinzufügen.
Genau.
Aber braucht man das in der Regel? Steht nicht das, was so ein Objekt tun muss, weitgehend vorher fest?
Nein, nein. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel jetzt ein Java-Klassendiagramm ansieht, sieht man, dass es sehr verzweigt ist, sehr tief ist. In Ruby hat man nie so verzweigte Klassenhierarchien. Man schafft, wenn man jetzt... Diese Klassenhierarchie baut ja meist auf Inheritance auf. Eine Klasse vererbt die Eigenschaften der Superklasse. Ruby ist wie Java auch Single Inheritance, im Gegensatz zu C++, wo ich ja von mehreren Objekten ableiten kann. Was ich Multiple Inheritance nennt, was aber zu komischen Effekten führen kann, wenn ich gleiche Methoden in den Basisobjekten habe. Was in Ruby viel mehr der Fall ist, dass ich Eigenschaften in Form von Modulen hinzufügen kann. Das heißt, das sind sogenannte Mix-In Klassen. In Java spricht man hier auch von Crosscutting Concerns. Das sind über die Klassen Hierarchie hinweg Eigenschaften, wie zum Beispiel Logging, Caching, die jetzt in diese starre Struktur der Klassen Hierarchie keinen Platz finden, sondern einfach dieser Klassenbaums gegenüber sind. Und das kann ich eben auch dynamisch machen. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt sagen, dieses Objekt braucht Caching, dieses Objekt braucht Logging. Oder ich stelle fest, dass dieses Objekt jetzt diese Eigenschaft noch braucht.
Das heißt, generelle Fähigkeiten, die man im Prinzip in allen Objekten mal gebrauchen könnte, aber nicht immer braucht, die man so modellieren kann, dass sie sich überall hinzufügen lassen, aber die man eben nur manchmal braucht und die man unter Umständen zu Debugging-Zwecken braucht oder zu Tests von Optimierungen zum Beispiel gebrauchen könnte, kann man sich da sozusagen auch ausgelöst durch Benutzerinteraktion dazu entschließen, im Lauf des Programms diese Funktionalität hinzuzufügen, um dann mal zu gucken, wie es so ist. Und das lässt sich über diese Mix-in-Klassen realisieren. Und dann erbt dieses Objekt von der Seite nur an dieser einen Stelle noch eine neue Funktionalität, die es nicht über die normale Vererbung dieser Klassen-Hierarchie erhalten hat. Ist das richtig?
Ja, es sind aber auch durchaus Algorithmen, die ich hier initiieren kann. Wie zum Beispiel, ich habe Hash-Klassen und möchte hier einen MapReduce-Algorithmus initiieren. Wenn ich jetzt eine starre Klassen-Hierarchie hätte, dann müsste ich das irgendwo in den Klassenbaum einbauen. Und so kann ich das.
Also MapReduce, das ist so diese Methode, wie Google schnell seine Suchergebnisse findet, riesiger Datenbestand und man macht so eine Vorauswahl über dieses Mapping und reduziert es dann auf das, was man eigentlich wirklich braucht, in der Form, wie man es braucht, durch diesen Reduce-Schritt. Das kann man dann inwiefern parallel ausführen?
Das bezieht sich jetzt nur auf das MapReduce.
Achso, ich meine, nochmal um das Beispiel besser zu verstehen. Also wenn man jetzt so was machen wollen würde, inwiefern hilft einem diese Mix-In-Geschichte?
Das ist mir jetzt nur spontan eingefallen, weil ich, wenn ich...
Ich naggele dich auch auf spontane Ideen fest.
Es geht um Algorithmen, die ich auch so initiieren kann.
Wenn man jetzt von irgendeinem Algorithmus redet, sollte man ja auch verstehen, wovon jetzt gerade die Rede ist. Führ weiter aus. Das Beispiel mit den Algorithmen.
Ja, weil ich im Klassenbaum verschiedene Objekte habe, für die ich diesen Algorithmus gerne ausführen möchte, habe ich eben mit diesen Mixing-Klassen die Möglichkeit, diese gleiche Eigenschaft, wo ich den Code an einer Stelle definiere, das ist dann das sogenannte Modul, Algorithmen, diesen beiden Klassen den gleichen Code hinzuzufügen. So habe ich weniger Code am Ende bzw. auch weniger Debugging und weniger Arbeit insgesamt.
Wie zum Beispiel diese MapReduce-Funktionalität. Und auf was zum Beispiel könnte man das dann so anwenden? Du kannst mir jetzt mal zwei Fälle nennen, wo man dann sozusagen das selbe MapReduce über diesen Weg so injizieren wollen würde und dann damit eben entsprechend sich Arbeit spart.
In Ruby schwerer, weil ich ja keine statischen Typen habe. Mir sind Hash-Maps eingefallen, die ich in einem Fall, wo ich Strings behandle, in einem Fall, wo ich komplexere Objekte wie JSON-Objekte oder was, abspeichere.
So quasi so Mini-Datenbanken innerhalb des Programms, die eben bestimmte Datentypen verwalten. Und dann würde man sozusagen diese MapReduce- Algorithmus-Funktionalität separat modellieren und nicht als Eigenschaft dieser Klassen und könnte denselben Algorithmus und damit auch denselben Code quasi mal da und mal da zur Anwendung bringen. Also es ähnelt ja auch sozusagen dieser Mehrfach-Vererbung, nur dass sie dann eben sehr dynamisch ist. Man wendet sie nur genau in dem Moment an, wo man sie dann auch wirklich brauchen an der Stelle, ohne dass man die eigentliche Hierarchie damit verändert.
Genau. Und der Effekt ist wirklich, dass ich in Ruby allgemein sehr flache Klassen-Hierarchien habe. Klassen verärben sich selten über mehr als zwei, drei Ebenen. Man geht auch mit einer reinen Inheritanz einfach eine sehr starre Bindung ein. Und das widerspricht diesem Loose-Coupling, also das losgekoppelte Prinzip. Je losgekoppelter ich Klassen definiere, desto flexibler bin ich dann in der Anwendung.
Verstehe ich.
Das heißt, diese ganze objektorientierte Sache ist auch ein sehr starkes Element bei Ruby. Es ist nicht nur so, dass es da ja, wir haben auch Objekte, sondern es ist schon so, dass da von Anfang an darauf geachtet wurde und dass man das als gegeben voraussetzt. Und gerade so dieses Ding, was du sagtest, alles sind irgendwie First Class Objects. Also alles kann man irgendwie identisch behandeln, egal was es ist, egal ob es eine Zahl, ein String oder eben eine Funktion ist. Alles kann man irgendwo rein... stimmt doch, ne? Also Funktionen sind auch First Class Objects. Also ich kann, was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt so einen Array habe, wo irgendwie verschiedene Werte dahinterstehen, es ist egal, ob es irgendwie Zahl, String, Hund, Katze, Maus, Funktion oder was auch immer ist. Oder ein ganzer Pool von Objekten. Man macht das halt einfach so. Das heißt, man hat dann sehr abstrakten Sicht auf seinen gesamten Programmdatenbestand und kann alles irgendwie auf allen Ebenen miteinander kombinieren und muss nicht darüber nachdenken, ob man das jetzt an der Stelle nehmen darf oder nicht. Zum Beispiel bei diesen alten Sprachen wie C, das ist ja so eine Wand, in die man immer wieder reinläuft. Hab ich da einen Integer-Wert, dann ist das was ganz anderes als irgendwie eine Funktion, weil allein schon der Name irgendwie in einem anderen Namensraum ist und man kann das einfach überhaupt gar nicht zusammenbringen. Wie ist denn das mit den Namensräumen? Bei Ruby gibt es nur einen?
Nein, man hat auch die Möglichkeit, Name-Spaces zu vergeben.
Aber es befindet sich zunächst einmal erstmal alles in einem?
Genau, im globalen Namensraum. Also auch alle Funktions-
Methodennamen und so weiter sind alle in einem?
Wenn ich nichts anderes definiere, ich sollte Klassenräume definieren.
Na gut, aber es ist ja erstmal eine Stärke, überhaupt in einem zu sein. Die Sprache separiert nicht bestimmte Dinge. Dass das eine in dem Namensraum ist und das andere in dem Namensraum und die können dann nicht zusammen. Ist nicht der Fall. Und wozu wendet man diese Namensräume, diese Expeziten an?
Um Klassen voneinander zu trennen. Also... Ein praktisches Anwendungsbeispiel wäre jetzt irgendwelche admin-Geschichten in einer Web-Anwendung. Da gibt es einen eigenen Namespace, Admin, und da mache ich nur die Controller rein, die für die Admin-Bereiche da sind oder nur die Modellklassen, die der Admin sehen darf und operieren darf, um hier von der normalen Anwendung jetzt das Ganze zu trennen.
Und wie sieht das denn konkret aus? Man schreibt da irgendwas davor, oder was?
Genau, du schreibst den Namespace davor, Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt, und... Du kannst ja so Objekte von anderen Namensräumen aufrufen, bzw. definieren tust du sie auch über Module. Module kannst du dann auch namens... Namespaces definieren.
Das bringt mich ja auch zu der Frage, wie man jetzt überhaupt sein Programm strukturiert. Also, wie teile ich... Wie teile ich jetzt mein Programm auf? Also hast du jetzt mehrfach gesagt, Module, was ist das? Sind das Dateien? Oder sind das Gruppen von Dateien, die man an einer anderen Stelle zu einem Modul deklariert? Oder ist irgendwie ein Datei ein Modul? Oder kann ein Modul, können auch mehrere Module in einer Datei sein?
Das ist beliebig.
Das ist beliebig?
Es ist nicht ganz. Also zum Beispiel in Rails wird erwartet, dass das Modul in einer bestimmten Klasse definiert wird. Aber im Prinzip, wie gesagt, ist ja alles ausfügbarer Code. Ich kann ja in der Konsole genau die gleichen Sachen schreiben. Die muss ich jetzt nicht in einer Datei definieren.
Na gut, aber was ist dann ein Modul? Ist also ein Modul ein eigener Namensraum? Oder ist ein Modul eine eigene Datei? Oder ist ein Modul etwas, wo steht, dass es ein Modul ist? Was muss ich schreiben, um ein Modul zu erhalten?
Es wird mit dem Keyword Module definiert. Und man definiert das in der Regel schon in einer eigenen Datei, die genauso auch heißt.
Also die Konvention ist sozusagen ein Modul, eine Datei, aber es müsste nicht so sein. Das kann man auch in einer Datei irgendwie sich modulieren. Und diese Module sind dann untereinander wodurch getrennt? Abgeschlossen wird alles mit der End. Was unterscheidet dann sozusagen den Code, der sich in dem einen Modul befindet, von dem Code, der sich in dem anderen Modul befindet? sollte ich überhaupt da noch eine Modulklammer drum rumsetzen, wenn ich alles in einer Datei habe?
Um den Code voneinander zu trennen. Ich inkludiere ja dieses Modul dann in andere Klassen.
Und dann kommt dieser Namensraum zum Spiel?
Der Namensraum ist eine andere Sache, die ich mit Modules definiere. Ich kann dann innerhalb von Modules wiederum Klassen definieren, die sind nur in diesem Bereich wiederum gültig.
Also das ist eine reine Sichtbarkeitsgeschichte?
Das ist eine Sichtbarkeitsgeschichte.
Das heißt, ich kann Dinge, die in einem Modul sind, nur dann benutzen, wenn ich sie implizit importiere?
dementsprechend aufrufe. Wie gesagt, mit diesem Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt 3 nicht, definiere ich den Namespace oder rufe ich den Namespace auf.
Ok, also der Namensraum ist der Name des Moduls. Also Namensraum und Modul hängt zusammen. Das ist sozusagen dasselbe. In dem Moment, wo ich ein Modul mache, mache ich auch einen Namensraum auf. Hans, jedes Modul hat einen eigenen Namensraum und ich kann ihn direkt ansprechen über seinen Namen. Ich kann ihn aber auch in meinen eigenen Namensraum hinein importieren, als wäre es sozusagen da drin. Und was macht man da normalerweise?
Beides?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Ja, wenn ich einen Namensraum definieren möchte, verwende ich einen Namensraum. Wenn ich Eigenschaften, wenn ich Methoden in meine Klasse definieren möchte, wie bestimmte Algorithmen jetzt, Positionierungsalgorithmen oder Geo-Hashing, keine Ahnung, wo ich einfach eine Sammlung von Methoden habe, dann inkludiere ich dann das Modul.
Und dann ist es sozusagen da, als wäre es, würde es zum Standard-Rüstzeug meiner Sprache sein?
Also hätte ich das in dem Objekt, genau.
Ja, sonst ist man ja auch so ein bisschen abhängig von diesem Namen dieses Moduls.
Wenn der sich dann mal ändert. Nee, nee, dann wären das Methoden dieses Objekts oder dieser Klasse.
Jetzt waren wir ja vorhin so ein bisschen losmarschiert mit diesem schwammigen Begriff der Dynamik und sind im Wesentlichen eigentlich erstmal bei den Objekten selbst gelandet, bzw. diesen Namensbindungen. Also ich kann halt alles Mögliche an einen Namen, an eine Variable binden. Und das ist irgendwie dynamisch. Was für dynamische Aspekte gibt es denn sonst noch?
Prinzipiell ist, wie gesagt, alles dynamisch veränderbar. Ich kann Methoden zur Laufzeit definieren. Auch hier gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Eine Möglichkeit wäre, was für einen Shower nicht möglich ist. Wenn eine klasse String definiert ist und bestimmte Methoden definiert sind, kann ich noch einmal diese klasse String aufmachen und eine neue Methode hinzufügen.
Wann würde man das zum Beispiel tun wollen?
Zum Beispiel, um einem String eine Translate-Methode hinzuzufügen. Ich habe dann, wo ich dann über ein Übersetzungssystem Strings irgendwo per Keyboard oder je nachdem direkt auch per String Also Translate im Sinne von Französisch, Deutsch, Deutsch-Französisch. Über ein Übersetzungs-Code, wo ich dann einen next-beliebigen String hernehmen kann.
Und dann ist das sozusagen eine Eigenschaft dieses Standard-String-Objektes, was man ja so gar nicht selber geschaffen hat, sondern was ja Bestandteil der Standard-Sprache ist. Das heißt, man kann auch Objekte, die out of the box dabei sind, selber um Funktionalität erweitern. Das ist eigentlich das, was dahinter steckt. Das heißt, man hat nicht so ein geschlossenes System. Und wenn ich irgendwie einen String, der übersetzbar sein soll, schaffen will, dann muss ich mir meinen eigenen Translatable-String bauen, sondern ich kann einfach den normalen, stinknormalen Stino-String nehmen und diese Funktionalität einfach hinzufügen am Anfang meines Programms und fortan kann ich dann beliebige Strings in Funktionen hineinreichen, die einfach erwarten, dass was auch immer da angeliefert wird, dass man das übersetzen kann.
Ganz richtig.
Das ist ja ganz pfiffig. Ja, ist gut. Das sind ja immer diese kleinen Details, wo man sich so recht keine Gedanken drum macht, wozulande das eigentlich mal alles gut sein könnte. Also Methoden sind jederzeit erzeugbar. Das heißt, man erzeugt sie und dann fügt man sie erst hinzu oder ist dieses Hinzufügen das Erzeugen an der Stelle jetzt so ein Ding. Also schreibe ich so wirklich hier, String erhält jetzt eine neue Methode, die heißt und ich tue die dann da rein oder erzeuge ich erst mal diese Methode und tue sie dann da rein?
Da gibt es auch verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Also die einfachste Möglichkeit, die ich jetzt genannt habe, ist, ich schreibe ganz normal class String und def ist das Keyword, um eine Methode zu definieren. Zum Beispiel def t, definiere die Methode t für translate oder wie auch immer.
Immer die translate. Immer dieser Hang zu kürze bei Purim.
Anyway, also ich kann die Glasse aufmachen und hier neue Methoden definieren. Ich kann aber auch mit, es gibt die Grundfunktion defineMethods, kann ich hier auch Methoden definieren und die dann Glassen oder auch Objekten hinzufüllen.
Oder auch nicht. Man kann die Methode auch einfach nur so irgendeiner Variablen zuweisen und dann hält man die sich sozusagen für spätere Zeiten warm und ruft sie dann auf oder übergibt sie an andere Funktionen oder tut sie in irgendwelche Variablen rein etc.
Auch eine Möglichkeit, ja.
Sind das dann dann anonyme Methoden, also eine Methode muss noch nicht mal einen Namen haben? Oder muss sie immer einen Namen haben?
Nein, es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten von anonymen Methoden. Also es gibt diese Glossures, das sind ja anonyme Codeblöcke. Es gibt aber auch ausführbaren Code, die kann ich aber nicht in Variablen speichern, die sind direkt anwendbar auf die Variable, die ich gerade behandle. Das verwendet man hauptsächlich für Iteratoren. Zusätzlich gibt es auch den Lambda-Ausdruck, bzw. die ProcObjects, das sind wirklich dann Codeblöcke, die ich in Variablen speichern kann, anonyme.
Lambda oder was sagst du das? Proc, P-A-O-C?
Procedure, genau. Und die sind nicht ganz ident, da gibt es kleine, feine Unterschiede. Eine der Unterschiede ist das Codebinding und was ein Return macht. Wohin ein Return springt, springt das aus dem Codeblock raus oder aus der aktuellen Funktion, die ich gerade aufrufe.
Wenn die so unterschiedlich sind, sollten wir sie vielleicht mal separat beleuchten. Also, unter Clojure ist das ja ein sehr allgemeiner Begriff, der in Poemiersprachen verbreitet ist. Und den es ja auch schon so bei Lisp geht, geht es ja im Prinzip darum, dass man überhaupt erst mal so anonyme Funktionen hat, die man einfach erzeugt. Und der Zustand der Welt um diese Funktionen herum zum Zeitpunkt dieser Erzeugung bleibt für diese Funktionen eingefroren. Und wenn man diese Funktionen später aufruft, kann sie mit diesem Zustand arbeiten und immer, wenn sie wieder aufgerufen wird, sieht sie immer wieder diese Sichtweise auf den Namensraum. Hab ich das nicht gut definiert?
Nee, würde ich jetzt alles definieren.
Oder kenne ich das überhaupt? Du bist ja jetzt mal erklären da.
Also, Clojures sind ja unmittelbar ein Code, der unmittelbar ausgeführt wird. Jetzt beispielsweise eine Array- oder eine Hash-Klasse. Wie gesagt, die Hauptanwendung sind Iteratoren. Und da speichere ich den Code jetzt nicht zwischen. Der wird jetzt an der Stelle ausgeführt, wo ich ihn definiere. Das klassische ist Each. Das heißt, ich nehme jedes Element eines Arrays und mache damit etwas. Mache damit etwas, was in diesem Codeblock definiert ist. Dem kann ich jetzt auch Variablen übergeben. Eingeschränkt. Aber als Eingangsvariable des Codeblocks ist sozusagen das Element, was ich jetzt übergebe. Definiert sind diese Codeblocks, also die Methoden. Jetzt beispielsweise Each. Das iteriert durch das Array durch. Und dann gibt es das Zauberwort Yield. Yield springt dann in diesen Codeblock, den ich hinter dem Array definiert habe, das sogenannte Clojure, und übergibt das Element, das aktuelle Element, dem Codeblock. Andere Beispiele wären jetzt Find. Das heißt, ich gehe Array durch und retöre alle Werte, die eine bestimmte Bedingung erfüllen.
Die beiden Sachen, die du nicht gerade erklärt hast, ist das nicht das klassische Map und das klassische Reduce?
Das Reduce bzw. Inject, da gibt es Synonyme. Was ist das? Da gibt es noch andere. Reduce, Inject, das fällt mir gerade nicht ein. Das macht Folgendes, das ist genauso ein Clojure. Hier übergebe ich aber einen Anfangswert. Das reduziert dann das Area oder was auch immer, die Collection-Klasse auf einen bestimmten Wert. Der wird immer wieder bei jeder Iteration diesen Codeblock übergeben. Zusätzlich das aktuelle Element. Hier kann ich Summen bilden, hier kann ich klassische Fibonacci-Nummern, wo ich immer wieder den Rentörenwert des Clojures als neuen Eingangswert beim nächsten Auftrag übergebe.
Das heißt, grundsätzlich sind diese Kleinstfunktionen, anonyme Funktionen und Clojures extrem nützlich, wenn es darum geht, komplexe Datenstrukturen durchzumarschieren, durch zu analysieren, zusammenzufassen, Sachen zu suchen, etc.
Unheimlich praktisch. Dadurch kann man auch sehr kompakten Code schreiben. Wie gesagt, ich kann ja diese Iteratoren, die es gibt, Each, das sind ja ganz normale Methoden, die definiert sind, kann ich meine eigenen Methoden definieren, aber mit den fertigen Methoden kann man halt unheimlich viel machen.
Erklär mal, was ein Iterator genau macht und was es ist.
Ein Iterator geht eine Collection-Glasse durch und iteriert über diese Collection-Glasse und macht mit jedem Element etwas. Also es nimmt jedes Element einmal ran und nimmt es als Eingangsparameter für das Kloscher. Da gibt es die Möglichkeit, eben Each mache mit jedem Element etwas.
Also du redest jetzt von einer bestimmten Gruppe von Keywords in der Sprache Ruby, die Iteratoren sind.
Das sind keine Keywords. Das sind genauso definierte Methoden.
Die man auch selbst definieren kann. Das heißt, man kann auch jedem beliebigen Datensammlung eigene Iteratoren, die eine bestimmte Art und Weise haben, wie man durch diesen Datenwald durchmarschiert, hinzufügen, die dann eben von anderen benutzt werden können.
Ganz richtig.
Aber da gibt es dann auch Standard-Iteratoren, die man dann quasi definiert oder überlädt? Der nächste, der letzte?
In der Regel definiert man sich nicht die eigenen Methoden. Das ist schon so wie ein eingebautes Keyword, aber man verwendet sie halt im Alltag sehr oft. Zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt auch mit eingebaut, aber es gibt ein Each, an Each with Index. Denkbar wäre, dass ich jedes zweite Element nehme und damit etwas mache oder solche Sachen halt. Oder Collect. Ich gehe jedes Element durch und sammle jetzt nur bestimmte Eigenschaften der Objekte. Dann kriege ich eine Ehre zurück. Zum Beispiel, ich übergebe eine Sammlung von User-Elementen und sammle die IDs. Dann mache ich damit die Methode Collect und habe am Schluss dann als Return-Wert.
Also RAs gibt es, die hast du schon erwähnt.
Ja, Hashmaps sind wichtig. Das sind key-value-bare.
Das heißt, man kann einen anderen Wert finden, indem man ihm irgendeinen Wert als Suchbegriff gibt und das ist dann ein String?
Genau, beim ARI ist er der Index, der Zugriffsoperator, bei der Hashmap ist es der Key.
Der Key ist ein String. Also man schreibt ihn als String. Oder kann es auch irgendwas sein? Aber er baut sozusagen aus dem, was der Zugriff ist. Ich habe jetzt irgendwie da so mein... Wie groß ist Hund, Katze, Maus? Dann kann ich Hund, Katze, Maus als String formulieren. Dann wird es aber in diesem Objekt als Hash gespeichert. Er fasst den String zu einer Zahl zusammen, um einen schnellen Zugriff zu ermöglichen. Er durchsucht nicht jedes einzelne Element, bis er dann den Hund gefunden hat, sondern er ist in der Lage, über den Suchbegriff, den Key, sofort auf den entsprechenden Value zu schließen, oder zumindest sehr schnell.
Was wir noch nicht gesprochen haben, ist, dass es in Ruby auch einen Typen gibt, das nennt sich Symbol. Ist im Prinzip sehr ähnlich, wird ihn in Rails relativ häufig verwendet, um bestimmte Eigenschaften zu verleihen. Oder auch Zugriffsoperationen. Symbol last in einer Collection-Klasse, oder first, das sind so Keywords, die...
Das heißt, es ist auch sozusagen nur ein Hash-Wert, den man aber schreibt wie ein Wort?
Ja, definiert wird ein Hash-Wert. Eigentlich ist es eher wie ein String. Aber das sind wiederverwendbare Symbole. Mit Doppelpunkt vorangeschrieben.
Doppelpunkt last schreibe, dann ist das sozusagen das Symbol namens last.
Genau, und wird immer wieder verwendet. Das heißt, es ist nicht jedes Mal neu definiert.
Und das kann man dann zum Beispiel so in seine... in seinen Erre rein tun oder sonst irgendwo hin tun, dann wird das als eigener Wert erkannt. Und es ist was anderes als eine Zahl.
Genau.
Das ist ganz praktisch. Das weiß ich.
Damit kann man eine Menge machen. Was gibt es noch? Also es gibt natürlich so die ganzen Klassiker. Es gibt Strings, es gibt Integers, es gibt irgendwie Floating Point. Das muss man ja schon fast gar nicht mehr erwähnen heutzutage.
Wobei hier auch, was ich schon vorher gesagt habe, es gibt keine nativen Klassen oder Objekte, wie es in Java ist. Es ist halt alles ein Objekt. Nachdem alles variabel ist oder einen Wert hat, ist auch eine Methode, Methoden, Klassen, alles als variablen Typen.
Ich wollte ja sozusagen auf diese Basis-Typen hinaus, die man sozusagen hat, bevor man anfängt, sich daraus seine eigenen komplexen Objekte zu bauen.
Bullshit-Ausdrücke gibt es auch.
To und false. Es gibt Poem, wir sprachen, ihr habt das nicht. Wie ist es jetzt sozusagen, in Ruby zu schreiben? Machst du im Wesentlichen Web-Anwendungen oder lässt du das Web auch mal weg?
Ich lass es auch mal weg. Meistens sind es natürlich Web-Anwendungen, die man schreibt, andere Anwendungsbeispiele aufgrund der eingebauten Regular-Expressions-Engine und der kompakten Sprache sind Data-Grunching. Aber wie du auch schon gesagt hast, das Ursprüng gesteckend wird in der Systemadmineration, dass ich hier alle Files durchrätteriere und da bestimmte Sachen suche oder was Operierte mache. Aber in der Regel ist es Web-Anwendung, was man macht.
Also nicht, aber du würdest jetzt nicht sagen, dass es jetzt irgendwie im Wesentlichen nur dafür taugt, sondern es ist im Prinzip universell Ruby. Oder taugt es für irgendwas nicht?
Doch, definitiv. Ich würde es nicht für hochkonkurrente Anwendungen benutzen. Ruby ist auch in der interpretierten Sprache. Concurrency ist ein allgemein schwieriges Thema. Da gibt es ganz spezielle Sprachen, die irgendwelche Multi-Core-Prozesse hier besser im Griff kriegen, als Ruby tut, wie zum Beispiel Erlang. Anwendungsentwicklung. Es gibt zwar Mac Ruby, habe ich aber so noch nicht wirklich eingesetzt. Würde ich auch nicht mit Ruby machen. Nur sehr eingeschränkt.
Also Mac Ruby ist die Implementierung von Apple, die nicht auf dem Standard-Compiler des Ruby-Projektes basiert, sondern ihr eigener Kram, wo sie richtig compilen. Das ist dieses mit dem LLVM, das kommt da zum Einsatz. Da gab es ja auch schon mal ein CRE zu dem Thema LLVM. Muss ich mal raussuchen hier. Mal ganz fleißig mal auch die Querverweise benennen, wenn man schon mal so weit ist.
Das ist ja auch was, was man noch nicht gesagt hat. Ruby ist eine interpretierte Sprache und hier gibt es ja...
CRE114 war das.
Das läuft in einer virtuellen Maschine. Die WorldShield-Maschine hat man hier zur Verfügung mit einem Garbage-Collector. Meistens wird eingesetzt die MRI. Das ist die Mats-Ruby-Interpreter, glaube ich, die Erfinder von Ruby von Mats selber geschrieben worden ist. Ab 9.1.9 ist hier auch die Grundlage YARV, das ist yet another Ruby-Virtual-Maschine, Neuimplementierung. Es gibt aber auch Implementierungen wie z.B. Ruby-Neos, die selbst auf Ruby aufbaut, die aber einen eingebauten Just-Intel-Compiler haben. Und JRuby gibt es noch zu erwähnen, die in der Java-VM läuft. Und hier ist auch der Garbage-Collector einer der Knackpunkte, der bevormenzmäßig austauschbar ist. Kann ich so nicht sagen. JRuby behauptet oft, die schnellste Implementierung zu sein. Wobei Ruby auch vier gewisse Sachen von sich behauptet, schneller zu sein. Die sind aber auch stark in der Entwicklung.
Ja, Ruby behauptet das glaube ich auch, von sich ganz, ganz schnell zu sein.
Ist gut möglich.
Ich kenne aber die Zahlen nicht genau, deswegen frage ich blöd. Also es ist ja ähnlich wie auch bei Python, da gibt es ja auch zahlreiche Implementierungen in Java und in anderen Programmiersprachen. Ich sehe gerade, es gibt auch mittlerweile Ruby-Implementierungen in JavaScript, HotRuby und so weiter, was auch immer die taugen mögen.
Richtig kenne ich ja.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich so ein typisches Ding. Trotzdem wäre ja eigentlich so richtig in hochoptimierenden Programmcode, also Maschinencode zu übersetzen, um eben Performance zu gewinnen, ist ja eigentlich durchaus ein Ziel, was man eigentlich ganz gerne möchte. Aber da geht die Standardentwicklung des Hauptruby-Tricks nicht hin. Dann bleibt man erstmal bei der VM, bei dem VM-Modell.
Das ist ja auch einer der Kritikpunkte eigentlich an Ruby, wenn man jetzt schon sagt, wofür wir das nicht anwenden. Natürlich ist eine interpretierte Sprache jetzt nicht so schnell wie eine kompilierte Sprache. Aber die Idee dahinter ist es, oder die Grundidee auch von Rails-Anwendungen ist es, dass Entwicklungszeit-Developer-Kosten wesentlich höher sind als Maschinen. CPU-Power. Das heißt, man entwickelt lieber so, dass man sicher einen Cluster hinstellt, aber dafür wesentlich weniger Entwicklungskosten oder Wartungskosten hat. Das ist auch so eine Grundidee. Diese Performance-Geschichte trägt halt nur zum Teil, und ich kann auch sagen...
Manchmal sind ja auch Programme schneller, die ein halbes Jahr vorher anfangen, mit dem was letztendlich getan werden muss. Auf der anderen Seite hat man natürlich gerade im Web auch dieses Skalierungsproblem, dass man manchmal eben auch bestimmte Performance-Probleme auch jetzt mit mehr Computern nicht erschlagen kann, weil es sich eben nicht linear verhält, sondern man da irgendeine exponentielle Steigerung drin hat, weil einfach der Code den da nicht so in den Griff kriegt, dass man da noch so viele Server hinstellen kann, dass man es eben auch einfach nicht bewältigt bekommt. Aber müsste das nicht auch ein großes Thema sein, Konkurrenz in Ruby derzeit? Gibt es da keine Entwicklung dahin, dieses Problem auch mal anzugehen?
Na ja, es hat sich wohl mit 1.9 hier was verbessert, aber wie gesagt, für richtig hochperformante Geschichten würde ich es nicht einsetzen. Da eher auf andere Backends setzen oder auf hochperformante Datenbanken. Diese ganzen NoSQL-Datenbanken sind ja auch gerade ein heißes Thema in der Ruby-Welt. Nicht nur dort, aber dort wird auch sehr auf die gesetzt.
Ja, hier bei Chaosradio Express war das auch schon ein Thema. Wollte ich vorhin schon darauf verweisen. CouchDB habe ich hier mal besprochen. CRE125, wo ja auch diese MapReduce-Geschichte eine große Rolle spielt, wo das ja sozusagen das Kernprinzip des Datenzugriffs ist, eben auf so einem riesigen Datenbestand. Wir haben das ja eben sozusagen innerhalb des Prozessors in einem laufenden Programm besprochen. Aber diese Konzepte, die greifen ja wild um sich. Und im Prinzip ist das ja sozusagen nur die notwendige Konsequenz, wenn man es eben mit riesigen Datenmengen zu tun hat, beziehungsweise auch mit verteilten Datenmengen, damit irgendwie klarzukommen, dass es an der Stelle auch schon mal besprochen worden. Hier über Chaosradio Express. Ja, mit den Implementierungen, also ich meine, diese Konkurrenz, ich will jetzt nicht so drauf rumhacken, aber es ist natürlich schon auch so ein Aspekt. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt eine Interpretesprache damit nicht umgehen könnte. Also hier gerade so dieses Jungs von Google, den ehemaligen C-Programmierern vorgestellte Go. Ist ja im Prinzip auch eine interpretierte Sprache, die explizit genau dieses Problem der Konkurrenz angeht. Und auch in Mac-Ruby ist das ja im Prinzip mit drin, weil in dem Moment, wo es auf Mac aufsetzt, ja sozusagen das Betriebssystem auch solche Konkurrenz bereitstellen kann, die man dann eben auch von Ruby aus nutzen kann, da muss man dann eben sehen. Aber die Standard-Ruby-Sache kennt jetzt sozusagen keine Threts und kennt auch in der Sprache... Doch, Threts kennt es. Aber es hat keinen expliziten Support für Konkurrenz hier.
Naja, die sind eher, würde ich fast sagen, stiftkindlich behandelt worden. Das ist performancemäßig nicht so vorteilhaft gewesen.
Aber Threts gibt es?
Ja, Threts gibt es.
Und wie verwendet man das dann?
Gar nicht.
Ich habe es explizit noch nicht wirklich verwendet. Es war ja sogar so, dass Rails bis vor einem Jahr nicht wirklich FlatSafe war. Und erst mit 2.3 die ersten FlatSafe-Geschichten hinzugekommen sind.
2.3. Vielleicht nochmal in diesem Versionswald ein bisschen aufzuräumen. Welche Versionen spielen jetzt hier bei Ruby eine Rolle?
Aktuell 1.8.7. Das ist so die Basisentwicklung des Basis-Ruby und die neue Version 1.9.2 ist halt ein neuer Sprung, wo auch sich in Richtung Threats und Performance was verbessert hat. Die Virtual Machine hat sich unten ausgetauscht. Encodings internationalen Support ist hier verbessert worden. Das Problem ist, sie sind nicht kompatibel miteinander. Das heißt, man müsste wirklich den Code portieren.
Was ist.
Schreibweisen, wie man auf Hashtags zugreift. Mit den Encoding-Problemen habe ich schon gemeint.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall keine Syntax-Gleichheit. Man kann nicht einfach Code nehmen und von 18 auf 19 führen, ohne Nebeneffekte riskieren.
Definitiv nicht.
Das ähnliche Problem gibt es ja auch bei Python, gerade mit dem Marsch von 2 auf 3. Hältst du die Änderung für notwendig? War das eine gute Entscheidung?
1.9.2, ja.
Die Reißleine zu ziehen und zu sagen, wir müssen bestimmte Dinge ändern?
Gewisse Sachen, ja. Mit diesen Encodings, das war wirklich eine notwendige Sache. Die gefällt hat in Ruby. Der Support für internationale Drinks war sehr wichtig.
Man kann jetzt auch ein Ö ein tippen in den Sourcecode. Es liegt nicht gleich alles um die Ohren. Schon mal was wert. Wenn es denn funktioniert. Ja, verlassen wir vielleicht mal so ein bisschen die Basisplattform Ruby. Dann kommen wir nochmal auf das zu sprechen, was Ruby eigentlich wirklich populär gemacht hat. Haben wir ja eingangs schon besprochen, dass das sozusagen die erste große Welle war. Rails, ein Framework zum Entwickeln von Anwendungen im Web. Was ist da die Geschichte? Wie kam es dazu?
Rails wurde ursprünglich entwickelt von David Heinemanner-Hensen, ein dänischen Entwickler, der bei 37signals gearbeitet hat, an einem Projekt gearbeitet hat, das sich nennt Basecamp, ist immer noch aktuell online.
So ein Projektmanagement-Tool, wo man mit anderen Leuten kollaborativ einfach Taskverwaltung machen kann etc.
Er kam ursprünglich von der BHB-Seite und das Basecamp war auch, soweit ich weiß, ein erstes Ruby-Projekt. Er hat für dieses Basecamp ein eigenes Framework geschaffen, das ist Rails, das ist daraus entstanden. Und gewisse Sachen sind jetzt lange mitgeschleppt worden. Es gibt aktuell neue Versionen, die 3. Version. Da sind viele Sachen aufgeräumt worden, die seit Anfang mitgeschleppt worden sind. Aber im Prinzip, was Rails ausmacht, ist eine schnelle Entwicklung. Es gilt der Grundsatz Convention over Configuration. Man kann das vielleicht ein Beispiel von dem Datenzugriff veranschaulichen, bzw. Datenbankenzugriff verwendet als ORM-Mapper. Das nennt sich ActiveRecord. Das ist ein Framework innerhalb von Rails. ORM, Object-Dirational-Mapper. Das heißt, ich mappe meine Daten in Objekte. Ich habe eine Tabelle Users und mappe die jetzt einen einzelnen Datensatz in ein Objekt.
Was man sagen muss, ist, Rails ist dafür gedacht, Real-World-Datenbanken zu verwenden, die bis zu dem Zeitpunkt im Wesentlichen SQL war. Es gibt heutzutage auch diese Nicht-SQL-Welt. Da ist das nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Aber um das Tabellenmodell der SQL-relationalen Datenbanken in die Objektwelt abzubilden, ist eben genau ein solchen Abbildungslayer erforderlich, wenn man das nicht explizit mit Tabellen umgehen will. Das ist ja eigentlich das, was man nicht will. Man will ja möglichst abstrakt mit einem Store sprechen und sagen, ich habe hier so meine User. Das sind irgendwie Objekte, die hängen zusammen. Und um das eben in so einer SQL-Welt abzubilden, ist dieser Zwischenlayer erforderlich oder zumindest ist das mal erfunden worden, um genau eben diese Abstraktionsebene zu schaffen. Und das heißt bei Rails, ActiveRecord?
Bis Rails 2. Es gibt auch andere. In Rails 3 ist modularer aufgebaut, aber das können wir dann später nochmal behandeln. Es ist auch möglich, andere einzusetzen. Datamapper.
Das heißt, es gibt nicht nur diesen einen, sondern es gibt dann viele und man sucht sich einen aus?
So viele gibt es nicht, das sind die beiden mir bekannten. Datamapper, der ist viel schmaler als ActiveRecord. In ActiveRecord muss ich die Spalten, meistens werden die Spalten in Attribute gemapped. Ich habe ein Attribut Name und das spiegelt eine Spalte in meiner Datenbank Name wieder. In ActiveRecord muss ich die nicht einmal definieren. Da rufe ich einfach ein Attribut Name auf. Und ich habe vorhin schon gesagt, Ruby hatte diese Möglichkeit, Method Not Found oder Kunst Not Found oder darüber nachzuschauen, gibt es diese Spalte, also definiere ich dynamisch das Attribut.
Das heißt, sie wurde dann einfach eingerichtet?
Die wurde dann einfach zur Laufzeit eingerichtet. Ich kann schon von vorn an darauf zugreifen, ohne dass ich es überhaupt definiert habe, dass es die Spalte gibt. Die gibt es einfach in der Datenbank.
Das war eigentlich ganz pfiffig.
Hat aber viele Vorteile, vor allem bin ich sehr schnell. Es hat aber auch Nachteile, Übersichtlichkeit usw. In Datamapper, ich will oft nicht alle spalten, in Datamapper muss man das explizit machen. Das ist insgesamt auch schlanker gehalten. Aber ActiveRecord ist definitiv sozusagen der Hauptmapper. Und die meisten werden auch damit arbeiten. Ich habe auch die Möglichkeit, Assoziationen zu definieren. Da gibt es auch per Symbolschreiweise HasMany z.B. Ein User hat mehrere Adressen oder Bilder, z.B.
E-Mail-Adressen.
E-Mail-Adressen sind jetzt keine, wenn man die wieder in eigenen Tabellen speichern würde, ich meine jetzt wirklich eine Assoziation zu einer anderen Tabelle über einen Foreign Key.
Okay, hat viele Bilder.
Genau, da gibt es dann eine Tabelle Fotos mit einem Foreign Key User ID, die zurückverweist. All das sind Sachen, die ich nicht definieren muss. Das ist so eine Art Konvention.
Wo muss ich die nicht definieren? Wenn ich ActiveRecord verwende, muss ich die nicht definieren?
Genau, ich habe einfach dann mit dem Keyword HasManyFotos, weiß ActiveRecord, es muss nachschauen in einer Tabelle Fotos, ein foreign key namens user, underscore id. Kann ich auch überschreiben, aber das ist die Konvention. Mit diesem Symbol HasMany werden mir auch viele Methoden dynamisch hinzugefügt. Zum Beispiel kann ich ein Foto für einem User dynamisch erzeugen. Ich sage user.photos.create. Ich könnte dann hier Namen und so weiter übergeben. Das wird für diesen User, der foreign key wird automatisch eingesetzt, erzeugt. Ich kann überprüfen, gibt es überhaupt Fotos? Kann ich alle Fotos des Users löschen? Das sind alles Methoden, die dann hinzugefügt werden. Ich kann aber auch sagen, es gibt diese FindBy-Methoden, User, FindBy-Name. Diese Methode ist nirgendwo definiert, aber mit diesem MethodMissing-Trick wird diese Methode, die Konvention MethodMissing, habe ich die Möglichkeit, der Methoden-Name wird übergeben und per Regular Expression wird überprüft. FindAnderscoreBy. Das könnte jetzt ein gewünschtes SQL-Statement sein, oder ich will daraus ein SQL-Statement generieren. Wenn hier nachher noch ein Anderscore-Attribut-Name kommt, der sich als Spalte widerspiegelt, definiere ich diese Methode und ich weiß, dass ich dieses SQL selektiere mir alles vom User, wer Name ist gleich.
Das heißt, die Grundidee von ActiveRecord ist, einen so weit wie möglich von den Details der Datenbank und dem ganzen SQL fernzuhalten?
Ja, auch eine schnelle Anwendung. Das sind Sachen Feind bei Name. Das, was ich jetzt erzählt habe, ist relativ komplex. Das muss man aber gar nicht wissen. Man kann damit arbeiten und das ist auch relativ eingängig. Das merkt man sich sofort, dass man das anwenden kann, ohne dass es irgendwo definiert ist.
ActiveRecord ist aber jetzt nur ein Teil von diesen Rails. Ich habe gerade das Gefühl, man müsste vielleicht noch mal so eine Etage nach oben marschieren und sich das Ganze mal so von oben anschauen. Also wenn ich jetzt sage, okay, alles klar, ich möchte jetzt eine Web-Anwendung machen. Keine Ahnung. Ich möchte vielleicht so eine Art Terminkalender für meine Arbeitsgruppe bauen. Um ein blödes Beispiel zu nennen. Aber da müssen ja mehrere Leute über das Web zugreifen und da ihre Termine eintragen. Und andere wollen das irgendwie sehen. Und da ist man ja so im Wesentlichen an so einer gemeinsamen Datenbank zugange, die ja dann auch, was weiß ich, schnell nicht Trivialität erreichen kann. Aber ist jetzt auch nicht so ein kompliziertes Beispiel. Wie geht man da überhaupt heran? Also, sagen wir mal, ich habe mich jetzt aus welchen Gründen auch immer für Ruby und Rails entschieden und sag so, das ist jetzt irgendwie das, womit ich das umsetzen will. Was tue ich? Also, wo fange ich an? Wie denkt dieses Rails? Was setzt es bei mir voraus, dass ich es von ihm verstanden habe, um die richtigen Schritte machen zu können?
Ja, da gibt es ja das berühmte Video von eben David Heiner-Meiner-Hensen, wo er Rails vorgestellt hat, wo er in 5 Minuten seinen Blog generiert hat. Mit dem ist Rails auch bekannt geworden. Im Prinzip jede Rails-Anwendung folgt einer bestimmten Ordnerstruktur. Ich habe meinen Ordner-App, da sind die Controller definiert. Ein Controller arbeitet ja Web-Requests ab. Ich habe einen Conf-Ordner, wo meine Konfiguration drin ist.
Das ist zum Beispiel Stopp.
Controller. Jetzt sind wir glaube ich bei dem MVC-Konzept richtig angekommen.
Genau, das ist ein ganz wichtiges Konzept.
Genau, vielleicht sollten wir die wichtigen Konzepte zuerst erklären. Model-View-Controller ist ja eine gute alte Geschichte, die ja auch aus Smalltalk herauskommt. Da sind wir wieder bei den Ursprüngen. Damals als Konzept entworfen, wie man grafische Benutzerbohrflächen macht. Smalltalk war ja schon von Anfang an gedacht für grafische User-Interaktionen und kannte irgendwie Fenster und diesen ganzen Klimbim. Und da ist ja diese Abstraktion von Model-View-Controller geboren worden. Und, das richtig verstehe, hat Rails dieses Konzept übernommen. Oder zumindest diese Grunddenker. Was wird hier unterschieden?
Also die Controller handeln die Web-Requests ab. Und die ganze Logik, wie mit den Daten umgegangen wird, ist in eigenen Model-Klassen. Die Model-Klassen sind dann die vorher erwähnten, zumindest in der Regel, Datenbankenklassen, ActiveRecord-Klassen, die sich auch in einer Datenbank widerspiegeln, muss aber nicht sein. Da steckt dann die ganze Datenlogik drinnen. Die Controller handeln diese Requests ab. Und sollten, so ist man in Rails der Meinung, möglichst schlank gehalten werden, der View-Code stellt dann diese Daten dar. Und der Controller sagt nur den Daten, wie er sie sich aufbereiten soll. Und die View weiß dann, was sie damit machen soll.
Das heißt, mein Programm ist im Prinzip dreigeteilt. Genau in diese drei Felder. Ich habe Code, der benutzt ActiveRecord oder im Falle von den neuen Rails, wie ist das noch gleich?
Data-Mapper. Das ist in der Regel schon noch ActiveRecord, aber das wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Okay, gut, da wäre eine Option, wie auch immer. Also ich benutze welches System auch immer, um mit meiner Datenbank zu kommunizieren und abstrahiere diesen Datenbestand in etwas, was eben ein Model-Objekt ist. Kann man das so sagen? Und des Weiteren gibt es eine Gruppe von Funktionen, die eben dieses Model befragt oder in ihm etwas sucht und herauszieht und sozusagen über diese Schnittstelle, die dieses Model-Objekt darstellt, auf den Datenbestand zugrafen. Das sind die Controller?
Genau, aber auch übergeordnete Logik machen, wie zum Beispiel Login. Diese Methode ist geschützt.
Also ein Controller muss nicht zwingend immer mit dem Model etwas zu tun haben, hat er in der Regel, aber kann auch irgendwelche Dinge tun ohne Datenbankmodelle. Er kann auch die aktuelle Tageszeit nehmen und auf der Basis irgendwas tun. Aber der ist dann quasi das Frontschwein. Auf den Controllern klickt man rum.
Genau, bzw. die bereiten auch die Daten vor. Je nachdem, was für ein Rückweis ich habe, will ich jetzt normalerweise HTML-Code zurückhaben? Oder will ich jetzt JSON-Daten zurückhaben? Dementsprechend reagiert der Controller. Da gibt es eine Möglichkeit Respond-to-Format. Je nachdem will ich HTML-Code. PDF oder auch kann ich ein eigenes Format definieren wie für das iPhone, dass ich sage, das ist jetzt nur speziell für das iPhone, wo ich die eigene Style schieße und das eigene Layout definiere. Kann ich dann darauf reagieren. Oder JSON-Daten, XML-Daten, was auch immer.
Der dritte Teil, der View, ist auch Code. Der aber dann sozusagen, der Wo zwischenklemmt, der wird dann auch von dem Controller aktiviert?
Der kommt hinten dran, genau. Ich sag dann, render dieses Template zum Beispiel. Rails arbeitet mit einer Template-Sprache, die aber austauschbar ist. Da gibt's erb, das ist sozusagen das Defo. Ist aber auch die Möglichkeit, Haml einzusetzen. Das funktioniert ein bisschen. Erb, das ist, weiß jetzt gar nicht, was das heißt.
Ist das sowas Österreichisches?
Was heißt denn das?
Erp oder was?
Das ist sehr HTML-ähnlich. Also im Prinzip ist das Ziel, diese Sprengversprachen. Daraus HTML-Code zu erzeugen. Und im Prinzip kann ich da, so wie in anderen Web-Frameworks, auch Variablen in HTML-Code einsetzen. Ich kann Teile von HTML nehmen, sie immer wieder darstellen, schleifen durchgehen, konditional zeigen. Das ist der Sinn dieser Template-Sprachen.
Das heißt, diese Dreifaltigkeit, das schlägt sich aber auch in allem wieder. Im Prinzip, wenn ich meine Rails-Applikationen schaffe, dann denke ich in diesen drei Kriterien, oder ist das nur so ein grobes Muster, nach dem man sich richten kann, oder auch nicht?
Nein, das ist eigentlich das Muster.
Das ist bestimmt mein Denken und Handeln und Strukturen. Das wurde dann sozusagen auch von dem Freiburg zu einem verlangt.
Ja, es gibt Ausnahmen, die aber schon sehr speziell sind, wie wenn ich wirklich ganz low-levelig irgendwas mit dem Request machen möchte. Das ist auch erst mit 2.3. hinzugekommen, dass ich hier überhaupt keine Templates verwende, sondern hier Proxy-Dienste oder ich weiß nicht was. Also darunter liegt Rec, das ist sozusagen die low-levelige Engine, die die Request abhandelt. Ich kann hier auch schon hineingehen und auf das ganze Glimpium drum herum verzichten. Das sind aber wirklich sehr spezielle Sachen. Zum Beispiel File-Uploads wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Denkst du denn, dass dieses Model-View-Controller-Modell die richtige Wahl war? Also ist das irgendwie eine tolle Idee? Vielleicht kann man es ja mal so betrachten. Was ist jetzt sozusagen das Tolle an Rails? Wenn man ja bis zu ein paar Eigenschaften gehört, dann kann man sagen, okay, so machen das ja vielleicht alle.
Na die Sauberkeit, die Schnelligkeit der Entwicklung. Was ich schon vorher gesagt habe, dass es sehr viele Konventionen gibt, wo ich sehr wenig Code schreiben muss und trotzdem weiß, was gemeint ist. Ich bin allerdings mit Rails 2, also das ist jetzt nicht das Framework schlecht hingewiesen. Es gab dieses Alternativ-Framework, Merp, das hat einige Sachen besser gemacht. Man hat sie immer so als Hacker-Framework hingestellt. Rails hat einige Sachen nicht gut können, wie z.B. Long-Warning-Requests. Es hat auch gewisse Sachen, nachdem es schon lange Last mitgeschleppt hat, ich habe das erzählt, das war das erste Ruby-Projekt von David Hennemeyer-Hensen, waren gewisse Sachen undurchschaubar. Es war nicht modular aufgebaut, ich konnte Sachen nicht austauschen, oder nur ganz schwer austauschen, da musste man herumhacken. Das war in Merb besser.
Wie schreibt sich Merb?
M-R-B. M-R-B. Das ist von einem Typen namens, mit einem ganz untersprechlichen Namen, Esra irgendwas, sehr viel im Umfeld von Engine Yard, beziehungsweise jetzt dann auch Yehuda Katz, der ja auch den Merge gemacht hat. Das ist ja die große Weiterentwicklung von Rails 2 gewesen, und auch für viele eine große Überraschung. Rails 3 ist im Prinzip Rails 2 plus Merb. Die haben gemerged.
Aha, und was kam dann sozusagen dann dazu, dadurch?
Na, es wurden sehr viele Sachen neu geschrieben, beziehungsweise von Merb übernommen, die in Rails einfach irgendwo, wo man angestanden ist.
Ja, aber es ist nur eine bessere Implementierung.
Modularer Aufbau.
Also eine bessere Implementierung des selben Konzeptes, was einfach besser funktioniert, oder komplett neue Konzepte, die damit reinkommen?
Nein, komplett neue Konzepte. Modularer Aufbau, wo gewisse Engines, wie zum Beispiel der ORM-App, austauschbar waren. Oder Rails, was wir jetzt auch noch nicht gesagt haben. Web 2.0-Umfeld hängt auch viel mit JavaScript zusammen. War sehr eng verbunden mit Prototype und Scriptaculous.
Also zwei JavaScript-Bibliotheken, die sehr populär waren am Anfang.
Genau. Mittlerweile ist GQuery auch überflügelt, ist hinzugekommen und sehr populär geworden. Merp hat von Anfang an auf GQuery gesetzt. Ein der neuen Grundkonzepte nennt sich Unobtrusive JavaScript, was GQuery besser umsetzt. Das heißt, dass ich mich auch nicht abhängig mache. dass ich HTML von JavaScript trenne. Dass ich nicht jetzt irgendwelche OnClick-Händler in meine HTML-Elemente reinschreibe, sondern dass ich das Trainer sozusagen GetElementByD, AddHandler, OnClick.
Müssen wir jetzt gar nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen, habe ich nämlich schon mal gemacht. Aha, wieder mal ein Plug hier, CAE146, sehr ausführliche Sendung zu JavaScript. Da hat auch jQuery seine Rolle gespielt. Das ist ja sozusagen eigentlich das, was so ein bisschen der Goldstein hat, ist derzeit so, wenn man irgendwie an Sachen herangeht. Das heißt, manchmal ist Ruby auch so ein bisschen das Opfer seiner frühen Entwicklung gewesen. Also überhaupt dieses Einführen von dynamischen User-Interfaces in Webseiten. So was wie diese Live-Suche, dass man irgendwas eintippt und dann kriegt man schon die Ergebnisse. Da gefrore einem ja noch das Blut vor wenigen Jahren, weil man dachte, wie cool ist das denn? Weil das kannte man halt einfach nicht von diesen statischen Formularen des Web 1.0 usw. Diese Komplexität, sowohl Code in der Webseite ablaufen zu lassen, als eben dann auch mit dem Zusammenarbeiten auf der Serverseite, dafür war ja so kein Framework bisher gemacht. Und Rails hat offensichtlich da eigentlich die Tür aufgestoßen, kann man sagen, weil es halt schon sehr früh eben mit diesen Bibliotheken, die du erwähnt hast, da überhaupt erstmal was hinbekommen hat. Nur war das natürlich quasi die erste Implementierung davon und wie das eben so ist, mit ersten Implementierungen von guten Ideen, irgendwann muss man sie dann eben komplett wegschmeißen. Das heißt Rails 3 ist insofern jetzt auch wirklich ein nennenswerter Schritt. Das ist jetzt nicht so ein bisschen Produktpflege, sondern das ist eigentlich das erste Mal, dass der große Besen genommen wurde und...
Wirklich aufgekehrt wurde, ja. Also da sind Sachen wirklich komplett aufgeräumt worden.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt heute in Rails und Ruby einsteigt, dann sollte einen auch nichts davon abhalten, gleich auf diese neue Version zu setzen.
Definitiv mit 3 anfangen, ja. Also das macht viel mehr Sinn.
Und benutzt man dann das alte oder das neue Ruby? Also das 1.8. oder das 1.9. Ruby?
Bis vor kurzem war es ja so, dass Rails 3 mit Ruby 1.9 noch nicht gelaufen ist, aber jetzt ist ja auch Ruby 1.9.2 raus und mit dem läuft jetzt auch Rails 3. Ist aber sehr frisch. Das hängt davon ab, was man macht.
Was heißt das, dass es jetzt der Bucky noch sein wird?
Nein, es geht um Kompetalität. Also eins der Stärken von Rails ist ja auch die Plug-in-Fähigkeit, dass ich meine Anwendung mit Plug-ins erweitern kann. Das betrifft aber auch, die müssen natürlich auch kompatibel sein mit 1.9.
Und das sind sie ja natürlich erst mal nicht so alle.
Genau.
Wie viel Prozent muss man da so vergessen, wenn man irgendwie jetzt auf 1.9 gehen würde? Wie viel Prozent der Plug-ins würden einem dann Probleme machen? Weiß man das?
Na ja, gut, es gibt eine große Menge. Die meist Gebrauchten sind schon kompatibel. Es gibt ja eine enorme Menge an Plug-ins, was wir auch noch gar nicht erwähnt haben, das ganze Paketmanagement, die Gems, was ja Ruby selbst betrifft. Die meist Gebrauchten sind mittlerweile kompatibel. 1.9 gibt es ja schon so eine Zeit lang, es war ja dann mit 1.9.1.
Also es ist ein Problem, was sich löst. Und so wie ich das immer verstanden habe, ist die Ruby-Gemeinde eigentlich auch relativ neophil. Das heißt, es gibt schon auch einen Dreiw in die Richtung des Problems, 1.8.kompatibilität oder 1.9.kompatibilität möglichst schnell vergessen zu machen. Oder gibt es da irgendwelche Könige, die da auf ihrem Hügel sitzen und sagen, man hätte 1.8. nie verlassen dürfen, früher war alles besser? Bleiben wir noch mal ein bisschen bei Rails. Vielleicht ist es ja so leidig, so komplexe Sachen wie Programmiersprachen in einem Audiopodcast zu erklären und man darf noch nicht mal einen Slide hochhalten, wo man sich den Sourcecode anschauen kann. Ich verstehe die Pein. Von daher sollte man vielleicht die Vorteile nutzen. Was sind denn Anwendungen, anderswo gefragt, was sind denn Anwendungen, die sich mit Rails wirklich cool lösen lassen? Also wo ist es geeignet und wo würdest du sagen, da schlägt es einfach voll ein und dafür ist es einfach gedacht und das sollte man dann so und so lösen?
Ich würde sagen, dass Rails für, vielleicht ist es jetzt hochgegriffen, 95% der Webanwendungen geeignet ist. Es gibt aber Schwachstellen, die zum Beispiel BHP voraus haben, auch aufgrund der Geschichte schon und des größeren Supports, Content-Management-Systeme. Das ist noch ein bisschen ein schwieriges Thema in Rails. Nicht, dass es prinzipiell nicht möglich ist, aber ich habe diesen Support nicht. Was auf der BHP-Seite wesentlich stärker ist. Ich bin jetzt nicht der Content-Management-System-Experte, dass ich sagen kann, woran es liegt, aber das ist...
Es gibt keine.
Es gibt nicht so wirklich welche, ja.
Woran liegt das?
Gute Frage, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe diesen Punkt schon öfter gehört.
Es gibt auch keine richtige Blog-Software, die sich so durchgesetzt hätte in der Rails-Welt. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie PHP sage, dann sage ich WordPress, so, ja. Und ab geht ja der Peter. Oder bei Content-Management dann halt irgendwie Drupal und ähnliche Systeme. Da gibt es ja dann immer so...
Ja, der Support für PHP ist definitiv stärker. Das heißt ja nicht, dass es so... Es geht ja um einen Eigenentwicklung, ne?
Das ist ein bisschen mein Eindruck, dass eigentlich in der Rails-Welt immer so die Custom-Lösung, die ist da irgendwie extrem stark, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen will sich so recht nie etwas herausbilden, wo dann alle drauf aufbauen. Woran liegt das? Da muss es doch... Gibt es da einen Grund für, oder ist das einfach nur so ein Phänomen des Weltalls, das noch keiner versteht?
Einen wirklichen Grund könnte ich jetzt keine nennen. Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht... Die ganzen Entwickler sind so stark beschäftigt, dass sie keine Zeit haben, irgendwelche Standards-Sachen zu machen. Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber das widerspricht doch eigentlich diesem ganzen Ansatz von Rails schon, was ja überhaupt erst mal einen Framework gesetzt hat, was ja dann auch alle anderen... Ich meine, wenn ich mir so anschaue, was in anderen Framework-Welten, in anderen Sprachen so abgeht, dann kopieren sie eigentlich alle dieses Rails-Konzept. Vielleicht nicht mit jedem System, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall mittlerweile in jeder Programmiersprache auch den Rails-Klon, der halt auch irgendwie MVC macht und auch die entsprechenden Schichtungen behauptet zu haben. Von daher ist das ja eigentlich durchaus so ein Postertschalt dann auch schon in der Web-Anwendung.
Einer der Punkte ist sicher die Unterstützung für Billigst-Hosting-Sachen. Die WordPress oder PHP laufen überall. Ruby, da muss man schon ein bisschen suchen.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein Argument. Wie sehr muss man denn danach suchen? Gibt es keine Hosts da, die sich jetzt auch auf Ruby spezialisieren?
In Deutschland eher weniger. Es gibt ein paar. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, Rails-Hosting, Rails-Hoster, kenn ich vom Twitter her. Aber wie viele Services sind, kann ich nicht. Es gibt keine amerikanischen Services.
Aber man muss sie sich schon richtig raussuchen. Es ist nicht so, dass man mit einer Pistole drauf ziehen kann und man trifft schon einen.
Genau. Slice-Host kann ich z.B. Ingenieure, ich glaube, ich bittete ja auch Server oder Serverspace an.
Na gut, aber gehen wir mal wieder weg von den Standards, die alle dann benutzen und weiter mitentwickeln. Wofür ist Rails gut geeignet? Und wo würdest du sagen, da kann man jetzt irgendwie...
Wie gesagt, für Individual-Software. Wenn du eine Web-Anwendung selber schreiben musst. Alles, was jetzt so nicht out of the box funktioniert, wie z.B. so WordPress.
Dann bleiben wir noch mal bei meinem kleinen Kalender-Beispiel. Dass ich mir das jetzt irgendwie so hacken möchte. Wie gehe ich da jetzt ran? Was mache ich als erstes?
Du generierst einmal deine Anwendungen. Du sagst...
Moment, erst mal Rechner aufklappen, muss ich irgendwas installieren?
Ach so, natürlich. Ruby on Rails musst du installieren.
Ja, das tue ich wie?
Seit Neuestem gibt es diesen Ruby-Version-Manager, RVM. Würde ich empfehlen, zu installieren. Der installiert deine Ruby-Versionen in dein Home-Verzeichnis.rvm. Und nicht systemweit. Mit dem Mac hat man Ruby ja vorinstalliert. Aber wenn du da mit anderen Versionen, wie zum Beispiel mit 1.9.2 herum experimentieren möchtest, wirst du das immer ein bisschen mit Farben umsetzen usw. Mit dem RVM kann man sehr schön zwischen den Versionen hin und her switchen. Außerdem, was ich ja schon kurz erwähnt habe, gibt es in Ruby ein eingebautes Paketmanagement, die Gems. Und du kannst mit diesem Ruby Version Manager Gemsets definieren. Das heißt, wenn man da mehrere Anwendungen schreibt, definiert man pro Anwendung den eigenen Gemsets, wo man dann auch hin und her switchen kann, ganz einfach. Und, wie gesagt, du installierst das alles in dein Homeverzeichnis, du kannst das alles wieder löschen, wenn du findest, das ist Mist. Die Ruby-Installation selbst bringt ein paar Sachen mit, wie das Paket-Management. Die meisten Sachen, die man sich installiert, kommen ja von GitHub oder die Gems. Rails selber kommt ja auch als Paket. Sagt man dann gem-install-rails. Kann hinten noch eine Version angeben, wenn man eine Vorversion haben möchte. Mittlerweile ist es Rails-Final. Also müsste man mit gem-install-rails auch die Dreierversion bekommen. Du kennst damit mit dem dash-dash-pre, dass man die Beta-Version bekommt. Mit Ruby kommen so ein paar Sachen mit. Paketmanagement, die Konsole.
Weil wir heute sagen, meinen wir September 2010. Muss man immer darauf hinweisen, weil CRI wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört. Die Leute wissen, woran sie sind.
Dann habe ich Rails-Soweiteinsatz bereit, wenn ich jetzt nichts vergessen habe. Aber das kann ich dann mit dem Rails-Kommando meine Anwendung generieren. Der generiert eine komplette...
Also alles spielt sich auf Kommandozeile ab. Oder kann sich auf Kommandozeile abspielen.
Das meiste, ja.
Und dann sage ich einfach Rails-Programmname. Zack, return. Und dann habe ich so eine Folder-Struktur, die da schonmal so rumliegt, wo... alles am richtigen Platz ist.
Genau.
Und alles erst mal so erzeugt wird, was man so erzeugen muss. Und dass man jetzt jede Datei einzeln anfassen muss.
Genau. Mit Script Server kann man dann diese Anwendung auch sofort hochfahren. Beziehungsweise jetzt mit der Rails-3-Version mit Rails-Server.
Mit Script Server?
Es gibt einen Script-Ordner und drinnen gibt es einen Script, der nennt sich Server. Das war aber noch Rails-2 aktuell. Mit Rails-3 heißt es Rails-Server.
Das heißt, da ist noch eine Web-Server mit dabei. Die muss man also auch nicht...
Genau.
Man startet einfach diesen Script und schon hat man irgendwas, wo man seinen Web-Browser starten kann. Dann kann man darauf rumklicken. Out of the Box. Das heißt, man hat schon ein laufendes Programm, bevor man irgendwas getan hat. Ganz richtig.
Dann hast du deine Datenbank.
Das ist dann leer, oder was? Das ist so ein leeres Programm mit Inhalt.
Successful Rails-Anwendung, der Name, Umgebungsvariabeln und so weiter.
Wir haben sozusagen erfolgreich nichts gestartet.
Und es läuft.
Man kann dann auf dem Nichts herumklicken.
Wie schön.
Ach so, wie sollte man auf dem Nichts herumklicken? Aber man könnte theoretisch, wenn man sich das Nichts wegdenkt, drauf herumklicken.
Na ja, in der Regel würde man dann zuerst einmal seine Datenbank konfigurieren. Es gibt einen Datenbank-Konfigurationsfeil, wo man einträgt, welche Datenbank. Man hat in der Regel drei bis vier Datenbanken, die man da einenträgt.
Was benutzt man denn als Datenbank?
Das kommt drauf an.
Was kann man denn als Datenbank benutzen? Was unterstützt denn Rails?
MySQL und Postgres von Grund auf. Da muss man dementsprechend Pakete installieren.
Das ist aber auch neu, dass Postgres serienmäßig dabei ist, oder? Das war von Anfang an nicht so.
Serienmäßig musst du die Pakete installieren. Nein, das Keyboard Postgres, das hat er, glaube ich, schon lange. Ich kenne es nicht anders.
Man kann Rails so aufbauen, dass es auch mit Postgres zusammenläuft.
Ich habe es fast immer mit Postgres zusammenlaufen lassen. NoSQL, SQLite meine ich. Das sind so die drei Standards, die es mitbringt. Es gibt sicher auch Oracle-Möglichkeiten, aber da muss man ein bisschen mehr machen. Ich kenne aber keinen, der wirklich damit arbeitet und Rails zusammen. Da trägt man in der Regel drei Datenbanken ein, bis vier. Das ist die Development-Datenbank, mit der man zu Entwicklungszeiten arbeitet. Die Test-Datenbank habe ich auch noch ganz vergessen zu erwähnen. Ganz wichtig, es wird fast religiös behandelt. Was ich aber auch sehr wichtig finde, ist Testunterstützung. Dass man, weil es eine Skript-Sprache ist, durch einfache Schreibfehler, kündender Fehler reinkommen.
Testunterstützung auf Rails oder auf Ruby-Ebene?
Beides eigentlich, aber in Rails nochmal vermehrt. Also, es wird von Anfang an ein Test.
Test-driven-Development ist glaube ich so das Buzzword.
Ja, bzw. es gibt sogar noch einen Schritt weiter. Behavior-driven-Development nennt man das dann da. Das ist das nächste Framework, das nennt sich RSpec, wo ich meine Specs definiere.
Das heißt?
In Ruby, das ist ja auch eine der schönen Sachen von Ruby, da es so dynamisch ist, kann ich auch DSLs definieren. Das sind sozusagen Domainspecifical Languages, wo ich lesbar, für andere lesbar, Sachen definieren kann. RSpec, das funktioniert so. Ich definiere zum Beispiel das Verhalten für eine bestimmte Model-Klasse. Nämlich ich schreibe describe, model, so und so. Dann gibt es das Keyword it. Und dann kommt jetzt Anführungsstriche. Das ist ein beliebiger String. Wenn ich jetzt einen User habe, should have a name, should have a valid name. Und schreibe jetzt hier mit ein paar vordefinierten Keywords, die in diesem RSpec-Framework definiert sind, meine Spezifikationen, dass zum Beispiel ein nicht valide Name das Model nicht valide macht. Wenn ich übergebe jetzt einen nicht validen Namen, erzeugst damit should not be valid. Das ist alles sehr leserlich, auch für nicht Programmierer lesbar.
Das heißt, man definiert so gewisse Constraints, die die Datenbestände erfüllen müssen.
Genau.
Daraus muss sich dann automatisch dieses das und das Feld ausgefüllt sein, vorher speichere ich das gar nicht ab, was daraus ergibt.
Also die Idee dahinter mit dem ganzen test-driven-development, das würde wahrscheinlich den Rahmen entsprechen, dass ich zuerst meine Tests schreibe und danach den Code. Das heißt, zuerst überlege ich mir, was will ich eigentlich, was soll der Code? Und dementsprechend strukturiere ich den Code. Vorteil ist, ich mache mir vorher Gedanken, was will ich jetzt eigentlich? Ich weiß, wann ich fertig bin, nämlich wenn der Test durchläuft. Tests zu schreiben ist aber meiner Meinung nach genauso schwer, wie wirklich programmieren zu lernen. Die Kunst ist es, aussagekräftige Tests zu schreiben. Es bringt überhaupt nichts, einen Testcode zu schreiben, der unleserlich ist. Wenn es irgendwie fehlschlägt, weiß ich überhaupt nicht, warum, was war jetzt. Dieses Behavior-Driven-Development hilft so ein bisschen dabei. Das heißt, ich mache mir wirklich über das Verhalten Gedanken. Ich mache mir Gedanken über ganz spezielle Sachen. Bei Unit-Tests im Allgemeinen kann ich ja beliebig lang machen. Da muss ich mir überlegen, welches Verhalten will ich eigentlich. Und das geht eher in Richtung Spezifikation. Das ist niedergeschriebene Spezifikation. Das Aspekt ist aber keineswegs an Rails gebunden. Das ist aber auch einer der Unterschiede. Merb hat von Anfang an eher auf Aspekt gesetzt. Während Rails die klassischen Unit-Tests und Integration-Tests usw.
Und Unit-Tests ist halt einfach so, man testet einfach, dass bestimmte Funktionen das richtige Ergebnis erzielen.
Ja, manche mögen das immer noch lieber. Da geht es auch in die Richtung, dass man schaut, dass man wirklich eine Sache pro Test abtestet. Dass man das nicht übertreibt, dass man mehrere Sachen testet.
Das ist ja auch ganz praktisch. Wenn man sich jetzt irgendwo in eine Funktion hineinlehnt mit seinem Ellenbogen und auf einmal steht da Quatsch drin, dann merkt man das vielleicht gar nicht. Bis dann eben so ein Test daherkommt und sagt, hier, da muss aber eigentlich fünf rauskommen, da kommt aber irgendwie Fubar raus. Und dann wird das einfach abgefangen.
Ganz richtig. In einer dynamischen Sprache wie Ruby ist es wichtig, hier Tests zu haben, weil es viel mehr Unfug treiben kann, weil ich einfach die Möglichkeiten habe.
Vielleicht zurück zur Rails-Anwendungserstellung. Also drei Datenbanken für Entwicklung, für Tests und dann eben für den eigentlichen laufenden Betrieb. Das heißt, man repliziert quasi das selbe Modell mal drei.
Nein, das sind nur Zugangsdaten für die Datenbank. Ich definiere User-Name, Password und Port. Da steht nur User-Name, Password und Port drinnen in der Regel. Oder was für eine Datenbank?
Wo drinnen?
In diesem Datenbanken-Konfigurations-File, von dem ich ursprünglich ausgegangen bin.
Aber dieses 3 Datenbanken-Aufsetzen für Development, Testing und Production, sind dann in den Datenbanken dieselben Strukturen drin?
Ja.
Das meinte ich. Also sozusagen dreimal dasselbe. Und je nachdem, was man jetzt hier gerade macht, ob man irgendwie am Testen ist oder am entwickeln ist, oder ob man jetzt wirklich ein laufendes System hat, wählt man dann die ein oder die andere.
Wie gesagt, beim Entwickeln normalerweise ein Development, das ist auch der Defo-Modus, das nennt sich dann Rails-Environment, das kann ich dann setzen oder bei bestimmten Sachen übergeben, wie zum Beispiel bei Konsolen-Aufruf übergebe ich das Environment, wenn ich ein anderes möchte als Development. Genau, das ist das Rails-Environment. Die Datenbank kann ich dann auch rake, das ist so eine Art Make für Ruby, von Jim Merrick geschrieben. Mit rake kann ich dann meine Datenbank auch aufsetzen, sage ich dann, wenn ich sie konfiguriert habe und die dementsprechenden Rechte habe, rake.db.create erzeugt die Datenbank einmal, oder rake.db.drop löscht sie wieder.
Woraus erzeugt er diese Datenbank?
Noch habe ich ja nichts. Er legt einfach nur die Datenbank an.
Ach so, okay. Er spricht mit der SQL-Datenbank, sozusagen. Man muss da nicht selber jetzt Hand anlegen, sondern er marschiert erstmal los, sodass erstmal alles da ist.
Und dann arbeitet Rails mit sogenannten Migrations. Eine Datenbank migriere ich, kann ich hinauf migrieren oder kann ich sie runter migrieren? Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt eine neue Tabelle hinzufüge, gibt es hier eine Sprache, was sage ich dann? Create Table, Users und so weiter. Oder wenn ich Spalten hinzufüge, wenn ich Spalten ändere, das ist im Laufe der Entwicklungszeit.
Kommt neue Attribute hinzu, etc.,
Was sehr vorteilhaft ist bei der Entwicklung, wenn irgendwer Spalten hinzufügt und so weiter, dass alle auf dem gleichen Stand sind. Die Tests kann ich nur laufen lassen, wenn die Datenbank sozusagen durchmigriert ist. Das wäre dann der weitere Aufruf, rektb-migrate, mit der bringe ich die Datenbank auf einen neuen Stand, auf einen aktuellen Stand. Ein weiterer Vorteil ist, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Production-Umgebung habe und ich habe Datenbank-Veränderungen, weil es ja die aktuelle Anwendung immer, was ist der Zustand, der aktuelle Zustand und was muss ich tun, um die Datenbank auf den neuen Zustand zu bringen und um ordentlich wieder zurückzurollen. Ich habe immer ein Up und ein Down in seiner Migration drinnen. Wenn ich jetzt bald den zufüge, wird beim Down beziehungsweise...
Quasi eine Versionskontrolle für die Datenbank.
Im Prinzip ja. Genau. Wie gesagt, sehr praktisch beim Arbeiten in Teams, aber auch für Produktionsumgebungen. Ja, das wär's zur Datenbank.
Jetzt ist eigentlich schon alles aufgesetzt. Jetzt müsste man nur noch anfangen zu programmieren oder muss man noch was tun?
Genau, es gibt dann Generatoren, die man zur Verfügung hat. Kann man benutzen, nicht benutzen. Es gibt den etwas umstrittenen Generator Scaffolding. Der machte wirklich komplette Webseiten für Modelle. Das heißt, mit allen Funktionen löschen und Indexseite und hinzufügen. Rails basiert ja sehr auf dem REST-Modell. In Rails programmiert man es ja keine REST-Full. Scaffolding erzeugt dementsprechend Actions dazu.
Das Scaffolding ist sehr grössbau. Man geht von einer bestimmten Standardprogrammstruktur aus, wo man die üblichen Schritte hat. Ich lege etwas Neues an, fülle es aus, speichere es ab und habe dann eine Liste davon und kann mir da wieder einen aussuchen. Die typischen Grub-Methoden. Aber er schreibt mir sozusagen einen Code, wie ich ihn selber schreiben könnte.
Ja, eigentlich ist es sehr schön, um Rails einmal kennenzulernen, das ganze Scaffolding. In der Regel wird man es aber nicht verwenden. Er erzeugt wirklich auch, weil er die Datenspalten kennt, und die Relationen erzeugt auch HTML-Code, mit denen ich dann wirklich auch die Daten zugreifen kann. Genau. Man kann es zum Beispiel für Admin-Interfaces ganz gut benutzen, um wirklich Daten hier über Web-Interfaces ganz schnell zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Aber eigentlich ist es so ein bisschen äh-äh.
Genau.
Weil?
Naja, weil der erzeugte Code, da gibt es bessere Methoden. Ist ein bisschen umstritten.
Man gibt ja auch so ein bisschen Autonomie auf, nicht? Das ist ja auch so dieses, man nimmt so, wie dieses Skript es macht und sieht dabei gar nicht, dass man es ja auch ganz anders machen könnte.
Genau. Ja, also selbst wenn das wiederkehrende Sachen sind, diese ganzen West-Hole-Sachen, gibt es hier Plugins, Make Resourceful oder so weiter, wo ich dann auch diese Standardsachen per Plugin zum Beispiel zur Verfügung stellen kann, dass ich nicht immer wieder den gleichen Code schreiben muss. Man kann sich aber durchaus die Controller mit den eingebauten Generatoren ohne den ganzen Climp-Inf und Scaffolding trotzdem generieren lassen oder die Models. Ich kann zum Beispiel, was ich gerne mache, wenn ich jetzt eine neue Struktur anlegen möchte, z.B. Comments, sage ich Script Generate RSpec Model. RSpec ist ja dieses Behavior Driven Framework. Modell ist eine neue Modellklasse. Comments, übergebte Spaltenname, Name, String, also vom Tipp String, usw. usf. Das erzeugt mir dann die Datenbankmigration, die Modellklasse, die noch nicht viel kann, aber einfach zumindest das File erzeugt ist. Und ganz einen einfachen RSpec-Test, also auch nur das Grundgerüst, das sozusagen Qualität überprüft. Und man arbeitet auch mit Fixture-Klassen, Fixtures für die Testdaten. Was ist das? Na ja, beim Testen ist immer so ein Knackpunkt, wie man mit Testdaten umgibt. Woher kommen die? Man kann die, und so hat es auch Rails vorgegeben, in sogenannten Fixtures. Die sind so in Jaml-Schreiweise datendefiniert. Das ist ein ganz einfaches Format, wo ich Spaltennamewert definiere und gebe den ganzen an Namen, zum Beispiel ein User, Quentin, Name, Doppelpunkt Quentin, Last Login, so und so viel. Hier kann ich Testdaten definieren.
Also die Testdaten sind die Fixtures?
Genau, die werden in Fixtures definiert.
Okay, also viele Begriffe auf einmal. Also YAML ist so dieses, ich will nicht XML schreiben, sondern ich schreibe es eigentlich so ähnlich, aber mit weniger spitzen Klammern-Format, so ein generisches hierarchisches Key-Value-Datenformat.
Ohne Klammern, das ist ganz einfach.
Naja, das meine ich ja. Es tut ja sowas ähnliches wie XML, nur dass man es halt nicht in diesem typischen XML-Style macht. Sondern mehr so der Unix-Admin-Way. Das stelle ich jetzt mal. Es ist eigentlich ein ganz sexy Format. Ich finde es gar nicht an so vielen Stellen wieder, aber es scheint auch nur in der Ruby-Welt wirklich Verbreitung gefunden zu haben. Und da drin definiert man dann sozusagen seine Fixtures, also seine Testwerte.
Genau. Ist auch nicht ganz unumstritten, weil es ist relativ statisch.
Na gut, aber es gibt immerhin einen Weg, das schon mal zu machen. Vor zehn Jahren war ja dieser ganze test-driften Kram nichts, worüber man geredet hat.
Und beim Generieren dieses Models sind dann schon zwei Daten. Ich habe ja die Spalten mit den Typen angegeben, mit irgendwelchen Defo-Werten vorgegeben. Kann ich dann auch meine Specs durchlaufen lassen, nachdem ich die Daten migriert habe, dann habe ich schon irgendwie Comments hinzugefickt. Wenn ich dann Foreign Keys definiert habe...
Sind wir jetzt eigentlich schon bei meinem Spezialbedarf mein kleines Kalender-Tool?
Nee, stimmt. Dann würde ich zuerst mal mit Users anfangen. Oder was soll das noch genau können, denn ich habe das jetzt nicht mehr so im Kopf. Du wirst Daten verwalten.
Ich will einfach einen gemeinsamen Kalender haben. Jeder soll da irgendwie was eintragen können.
Du brauchst User, du brauchst Daten, und du brauchst irgendwie eine Form Zugriffsrechte. Gut, diese beiden Modellklassen, die würde man sicher überlegen, was braucht man jetzt genau, dementsprechend das Modell generieren lassen, kann dann die Foreign Keys hinzufügen. Das heißt, ein User kann mehrere Kalender haben. Beziehungsweise ein Kalender ist dann auch...
Was meinst du mit Foreign Keys, genau?
Datenbanken, Foreign Keys.
Ja.
Dass die Daten in irgendeiner Form auserzügehren kann. Wenn ich die nämlich gesetzt habe, kann ich ja dann auch sagen, dass ein User has many Kalenders. Und das verweist dann auf das Modell Kalender. Und hier kann ich dann vom User aus auf die Kalender...
Also der key ist sozusagen, dass ich den Benutzer überhaupt referenzieren kann. Anfangs Sprache ist manchmal auch eine schwere Sprache.
Das stimmt. Ja, dann bräuchte ich dann noch die Controller. Da würde ich dann auch...
Also ich muss mir doch erstmal ein Modell ausdenken. Ich muss mir doch überhaupt erstmal ausdenken, was speichere ich? Und speichern würde ich ja hier Benutzer auf der einen Seite, die ja irgendwie sich einloggen müssen und denen ich irgendwie zuweisen will, wer was wie wann angelegt hat oder wer bei welchem Termin eingeladen ist. Und dann die Termine als solche. Das ist so jetzt das... Ich will es jetzt nicht zu kompliziert machen, aber das wären so die beiden Dinge. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt hergehen und dafür ein Modell machen.
Die würde ich dann so...
Die denke ich aber sozusagen als Ruby-Objekte. Oder denke ich jetzt in SQL-Tabellen.
Wie du möchtest.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Es gibt doch diese Object Relational Mapper. Ich dachte, der nimmt mir das ganze SQL aus dem Rücken.
Genau. Das habe ich ja vorhin erwähnt. Dass du das mit diesem Modell generieren kannst du ja dann alles auf einen Schlag generieren. Du hast deine Modellklassen und du hast deine Datenbankentabellen. Die werden parallel dazu generiert. Und du musst dir nur überlegen, die Attribute.
Die werden wo raus generiert? Woher weiß er denn, dass ich einen Kalender machen will?
Du gibst den ganzen einen Namen. Arsbeck, Modell...
Ach, das mache ich alles mit diesem Arsbeck.
Nein, das ist jetzt mein Weg, es zu machen. Aber das wäre ein Weg. Du kannst es natürlich auch bei Hand machen.
Ja. Welchen Weg du jetzt auch immer als den empfehlenswertesten empfehlen willst. Also wenn ich es jetzt von Hand mache, dann würde ich mir eine Ruby-Klasse schreiben. Die ein Model ist. Die dann irgendwie von irgendwie...
Wenn du es bei Hand machst, dann würdest du zuerst einmal eine Migration schreiben. Würdest du zuerst einmal eine Migration schreiben, die die Datenbank, die die Tabelle überhaupt in die Datenbank einfügt.
Weil du gehst davon aus, dass du eine Migration schreibst.
Das ist auch Ruby-Code, mit der du die Migration schreibst. Das ist auch... Da gibt es einen Syntax dafür. Create Table. Ganz einfacher Syntax. So und so. Spaltenname. So und so. Typ.
Also ich muss schon in dieser Tabellendenke auch denken. Ich dachte, ich mache mir jetzt hier einfach so mein Ruby-Objekt, weil es ja alles objektorientiert und super.
Naja, die Datenbank ist ja noch leer. Nur das Ruby-Objekt, da gibst du ja nicht die Spalten an. Du kannst eine fertige Datenbank hernehmen und hier dein Ruby-Objekt erzeugen und es kann trotzdem darauf zugreifen.
Aber kann ich nicht einfach nur sagen, ich mache jetzt hier einfach so ein Ruby-Objekt, das heißt irgendwie Termin. Und das hat dann so bestimmte Eigenschaften.
Nicht mit ActiveRecord, weil in ActiveRecord definierst du deine Spalten und Typen nicht. Das ist ein Datamap anders. Da definierst du wirklich, es gibt die Attribute und den Typen. Das definierst du ja in ActiveRecord nicht mehr. Darum geht es nicht in den Weg. Es geht in den umgekehrten Weg, dass du irgendwelche legacy Datenbanken nehmen kannst und darauf jetzt deine Model-Klassen einfach mappen kannst.
Okay, also es mappt mehr so von der Datenbank in mein Programm als von meinem Programm in die Datenbank.
Genau, du definierst das ja nicht. Das machst du mit der Migration, wo du sozusagen die Datenbank dann auf den Stand migrierst, den du haben möchtest.
Und bei diesem Datamapper, bei Rails 3, ist das anders?
Nein, Datamapper hat mit Rails 3, kannst du ihn nur einsetzen, wenn du willst. Genau, da definierst du die Spalten und die Typen. Und dementsprechend müsste auch der umgekehrte Weg gehen. Ich habe es jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert, was du jetzt von deiner Modellklasse in die Datenbank direkt hinüberträgst.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen dieser alte Traum. Hat sich ja nie so richtig durchsetzen wollen, aber so objektorientierte Datenbanken, das wird ja auch schon seit Jahrzehnten verfolgt. Da haben sich alle möglichen Firmen schon mal die Zähne daran ausgebrochen, weil es einfach deshalb so schwierig ist, wenn es an die Programmiersprache gebunden ist, dann hat es halt entsprechend kleine Audience und dann sind die Programmiersprachen halt auch lange Zeit nicht so geeignet gewesen, eben wegen mangelnder Dynamik etc. überhaupt so das alles zu leisten. Und dann war es am Ende dann doch irgendwie nicht effizient oder keiner wollte es benutzen. Und SQL hat sich halt einfach über die ganzen Jahre durchgesetzt, deswegen muss man damit jetzt irgendwie klarkommen. Noch nicht so richtig absehbar, inwieweit jetzt die NoSQL-Welle da ist.
Es wird nicht die regionalen Datenbanken ersetzen. Es ist ein Alternativweg.
Genau, es kommt wahrscheinlich eher nur noch etwas dazu. Aber irgendwie passt ja diese Programmierdenke mit diesen Objekten, wo man irgendwie alles schön verpointert und dadurch marschiert und da irgendwie seine Funktionen draufschmeißt und alles ist super und alles ist schnell und alles ist im RAM. Und dann kommt so dieser Massenspeicher-Aspekt und auf einmal ist das alles auf irgendwelchen anderen Computern, auf anderen Kontinenten, auf Festplatten, die kaputtgehen, wo man alles doppelt und dreifach halten muss und wo es langsam ist und so weiter. Und dann ist da halt nochmal so eine Software-Mauer namens SQL dazwischen, die ja nochmal so eine ganz eigene Denke aufeinigt. Das ist ja dann ist ja eigentlich total vernichtend. Also eigentlich würde man das ja alles nicht haben wollen. Deswegen ist immer so die Frage, wie viel von dieser mir auf auktorierten Denke der SQL-Welt finde ich letzten Endes noch in meinem Programmier-Framework für Web-Anwendungen wieder? Wie viel muss sein? Und auf wie viel kann man verzichten? Rails nimmt einem da auch nicht alles ab.
Alles kann man nicht abnehmen, weil es einfach immer ein Mismatch gibt zwischen den Tabellen und den Objekten, die man hat, weil du ja eben, wie du schon gesagt hast, Referenzen und so weiter, Objekte haben Hierarchien. Wie mappst du dann die Objekte auf die Tabellen und so weiter? Das funktioniert anders. Du gehst von Objekten, wie du auch schon gesagt hast, über Attribute links, hangelst du dich weiter, das kannst du so in relationalen Datenbanken ja nicht direkt. Auch wenn hier Rails so weit was übernimmt, wenn du nämlich die Assetationen definiert hast, weiß es, was es laden muss. Du musst jetzt nicht irgendwelche Select-Statements aufrufen, du kannst einfach die Attribute auf die Attribute greifen, die dann andere Objekte referenzieren und Rails lädt das für dich.
Trotzdem muss ich jetzt für meine Anwendung schon so ein bisschen die Datenbankdenke annehmen und mir mal überlegen, was ich so für Tabellen eigentlich haben will und definiere dann, mit Hilfe von ActiveRecord oder diesem Datamapper, wie das Ganze dann so in meinem Programm aufschlägt. Und dann habe ich entsprechende Klassen, die das sozusagen abfangen und die man aufruft, um dann eben die Daten wirklich zu abzubilden, wie zum Beispiel mein Termin. Das heißt, wenn ich dann irgendwo in meinem Programm, also in so einem Controller, der Meinung bin, jetzt müsste mal so ein neuer Termin angelegt werden, dann würde er sich an meine Modellklasse wenden und sagen, hier erzeug mal eine neue, und hier sind die Daten dafür.
Genau.
Und dann gebe ich das an dieses ActiveRecord weiter, und das kümmert sich aber dann darum, wirklich mit der Datenbank zu reden.
Darüber kommt noch so, in Rails 3 ist es auch abgekapselt, die Validierung, aber im Prinzip ist es so, ja. Kann die Daten natürlich vorher validieren. Ob die Sinn machen, ob die gültiges Format haben. Ich kann ja auch Hooks einbauen, das heißt, AfterCreate, wenn nachdem ein Objekt erzeugt worden ist, dass sich bestimmte Aktionen auslöst, bevor etwas abgespeichert wird und solche Sachen. Das definiere ich einfach so. BeforeCreate und Methodenname, der wird dann aufgerufen, bevor jetzt die Daten wirklich in die Datenmarkine eingeschrieben werden oder BeforeUpdate.
Also wenn man irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten hat, wenn da das und das drinsteht, dann muss eine andere Tabelle das und das drinstehen.
Oder irgendwas generieren möchte, Strukturen vorbereiten muss, was auch immer, genau.
Und jetzt? Was mache ich als nächstes? Jetzt habe ich irgendwie so meine Terminshowtour. Ich weiß, was ich da irgendwie drin haben will. Ich habe das irgendwie so in diesem Modell definiert. Es ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar, welchen Weg ich jetzt lieber wählen sollte. Also ob ich jetzt irgendwie das sozusagen von Hand mache oder ob ich diesen, wie heißt es noch gleich, R-Spec.
Es gibt Generatoren, du kannst es aber auch script-generate-model, ohne den ganzen R-Spec-Gram. Also wenn du auf Unit-Tests setzt, dann ist das der Weg. Ist aber synonym, macht genau das gleiche.
Okay, mit dem R-Spec mache ich das aber auf einem anderen Level und dann habe ich gleich diese Behavior Testgeschichte auch noch mit dabei.
Ja, ich mag es sehr gerne. Ich finde, da kommt sehr viel Brauchbares raus dabei. Vor allem über längere Zeit hinweg weiß man immer noch, was gemeint ist, was bei Unit-Tests oft nicht so der Fall ist.
Verstehe.
Ja, und dann was du dann natürlich brauchst, ist letztendlich, willst du die Web-Anwendung schreiben, du musst dir irgendwie das Frontend schreiben. Das heißt, du brauchst jetzt einmal deine Controller-Klassen. Wenn du es Restful machen willst, dann hast du pro Model-Klasse einen Controller. Das heißt, du hast einen Users-Controller und einen Kalender-Controller. Ein Kalender-Controller verwaltet die Kalender natürlich, kann sie anlegen, anzeigen lassen. Du würdest das wahrscheinlich verschachtelt machen, das heißt, Users, wie so diese Restrouten funktionieren, users-id-kalenders. Das heißt, das sind die Kalender eines bestimmten Users, wo du schon die URL, die Assoziation, die du gerne hast, herstellen möchtest. Auch das kannst du einfach definieren. Du hast ein eigenes Konfigurationsfeld, wo du deine Routen definierst. Und Rails stellt einen Keyword zur Verfügung. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau so, wie es funktioniert, wo du Ressourcen definieren kannst. Das ist dann einfach ein Controller, der dir dementsprechenden Rest-Routinen zur Verfügung stellt.
Langsam. REST steht für Replicational State Transfer und sicherlich einer der am wenigsten verstandenen populären Konzepte, die das Web so hergibt.
Die Idee dahinter, um es ganz kurz zu machen, ist, dass das HTTP-Protokoll besser ausgenutzt wird, um Datenbanken-Aktionen zu machen. Das heißt, HTTP bietet ja mehr als Get und Post. Es bietet ja auch ein Put und Delete.
Also, wir reden von den Methoden, die sozusagen Teil eines HTTP, einer HTTP-Anfrage sind. Wenn man heutzutage so auf eine Webseite geht und klickt, dann ist es in der Regel ein ich mache über HTTP die Verbindung, aber die eigentliche Methode, die ausgeführt wird, die Teil dieser Header-Anfrage ist, ist Get. Gib mal HTML, Alter. Und dann steht das auch genau da so drin. Und das ist irgendwie 99,999% aller HTTP-Request auf diesem Planeten ist irgendwie Get. So, jetzt kann man aber noch andere Sachen reinschreiben, wie irgendwie Put oder Post, was auch so für Formulare und so weiter gedacht ist, was aber auch selten genug wirklich verwendet wird. Und dann gibt es aber noch eine ganze Reihe von weiteren...
Eine ganze Reihe. Ich glaube, es gibt dann noch Delete.
Naja, es gibt dann zum Beispiel dieses Web-DAV, was das sozusagen alles noch erweitert, wo man so richtig Filesysteme über HTTP machen kann. Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von verschiedenen Werben, die zu der Gesamtwelt HTTP dazugehören. So, aber was versucht ihr jetzt Rest zu promoten?
Dass diese, wie gesagt, HTTP-Methoden für Datenbankenoperationen, Operationen an den Modellklassen ausgenutzt werden. Dass ich ein Objekt erzeuge, ich mit Post, ein Update mache ich mit Put, ein Destroy oder Delete mache ich mit Delete. Und die Index-Methode mache ich mit Get. Das mappt sich dann auf die URLs wieder. Users, slash, 25, einfach als Get, zeigt den User 25 die Show-Methode. Users, slash, Get, zeigt alle User an. Wenn ich einen User anzeigen möchte, dann ist es Users, auch die gleiche URL, users, slash, aber Postrequest. Und per Post werden die Daten transferiert, per Postparameter.
Also nicht, wenn ich ihn anzeigen will, sondern wie ich aktualisieren will, wie ich Daten reinschreiben will, meinst du?
Nein, aktualisieren ist dann die URL, users, du brauchst dann die IT, users, slash, 25, machst einen Boot-Request auf diesen User. Also das URL und Requestart korrelieren miteinander. Und das macht dann sozusagen die Datenbank-Operation aus.
Okay, aber mein Browser weiß davon erstmal gar nichts.
Muss er ja nicht, der muss es ja nur ausführen.
Und der sagt ihm, dass er es ausführt?
Na, das sagt dann dein Web-Interface, das du schreibst. Beziehungsweise dein Backend, das weiß, wie es auf welche Request zu reagieren hat.
Was ist jetzt so gut an dem Rest? Also warum will man das haben?
Weil du Sachen sauber voneinander trennen kannst, weil es einfach ein sauberes Konzept ist. Du kannst, wie gesagt, so verschachtelte Daten gut darstellen. Wenn du jetzt die Kalender eines Users haben möchtest, hast du zwar deinen Users-Controller und deinen Kalender-Controller. Durch die Route, die du definierst, weißt du aber, dass dein Kalender-Controller ein assoziiertes User-Objekt hat, weil der Parameter UserID dann für dich im Hintergrund mit übergeben wird.
Mit Route meinst du jetzt im Wesentlichen die URL.
Die URL, genau. Das ist das, was man in diesem Route definiert. Das sind das Mappen der URLs auf die Methoden in den entsprechenden Controller, die ausgeführt werden.
Also das steckt sozusagen in Rails schon so inherent mit drin, dass man so lesbare URLs hat.
Du kannst das einfach konfigurieren. Du sagst einfach, dass du diese Modellklasse oder diesen Control als Ressources definierst, d.h. als Restressource. Und musst dann gar nicht die Methoden, die es dazu gibt, definieren, in deine Route eintragen.
Also es muss nicht in der URL drin stehen. Man hat nicht so einen Slash-Delete-Tralala.
Du musst das nicht konfigurieren.
Das Problem ist, wenn man in seiner Browser-Historie vor und zurück marschiert und diese Methoden Teil der URL sind. Man geht dann da so hin. Dann filmt man dann einen Delete nochmal aus. Das entfällt an der Stelle, wo das von der URL getrennt ist. Also eigentlich ist Adressierung und was man damit tun will, ist separat.
Und du kannst das Ganze auch nested definieren, dass du dann den Kalender als Teil von User ansiehst oder aussätzt wird als parent-object. Dann musst du noch deine Templates definieren.
Also wie die ganze Sache aussehen soll.
Wie die ganze Sache aussehen soll. Du hast dann styleships, JavaScript. Da hast du aber auch schon Grundelemente dabei. Du hast dann deine Templatesprache, wo du dann Forms definieren kannst. Und so ist auch das Scaffolding ganz gut, wenn man nämlich lernen möchte. Wenn man Rails lernen möchte, dann weiß man, wie man diese Texte anwenden kann in dieser Templatesprache, weil das ja das mitgeneriert. Das generiert ja alle Formulare, die du ja brauchst, um Daten zu editieren. Die muss man ja erst...
Das heißt, mit dem Scaffolding kann man sich eben so einen Prototypen zusammenbauen, den man sich anschauen kann, um zu verstehen, ob es eigentlich hinauslaufen sollte. Aber man ist eigentlich ganz gut beraten, wenn man dann den Schritt wieder zurückgeht und sagt, okay, dann baue ich mir das jetzt auch auf. Aber ich habe das Licht schon mal gesehen.
In der Regel macht man es ja auch so. Also wenn du dann wirklich produktiv gehen möchtest, wenn du die Webseite online stellen möchtest, baust du das eh wieder zurück. Dann hast du halt für deine vier Hauptmethoden, den Index anzuzeigen, die Detaildaten darzustellen, ein neues Objekt zu erzeugen oder es abzudaten, hast du dann für diese vier Methoden jeweils Templates. Die kannst du miteinander share. Zum Beispiel das Formular kann man share. Fürs Editieren und Neuerzeugen muss man nicht jedes Mal neu machen. Das sind so genannte Partials, das sind dann so Teil-Templates, die du dann wieder verwenden kannst.
Das heißt, man kann sich auch das User-Interface modular aus einzelnen Templates zusammenbauen?
Ja, genau.
Und fertig ist die Web-Anwendung?
Im Prinzip ist dann die Web-Anwendung soweit fertig. Du hast dann noch dein Controller-Code, wo du dann deine Parameter übernimmst. Du hast aber deinen Params-Hash, den übergibst du dann ganz einfach deinen Model und sagst, wenn du jetzt auf Sicherheit keinen Wert legst, übergibst du das deinem Model und sagst Creators. Du kannst aber dann schon auch einzelne Attribute als nicht setzbar, als Massenattribute sozusagen bezeichnen, die du nicht darübersetzen kannst, ersperren sozusagen. Was du dann noch wolltest, die sozusagen kalenderfrei gehen und so weiter, das müsste man dann noch einmal extra einbauen, ob der User das auch darf.
Ja klar, ab einem bestimmten Punkt muss man sich einfach seine Applikationslogik dann auch einfach selber entwickeln. Aber soweit wollte ich jetzt gar nicht marschieren. Ich denke, das ist jetzt auch klar geworden, durch welche Pfade man dann verfolgen muss und wo man quasi an Rails und an Ruby andockt oder wo man eben auch an sein eigenes Hirn mal andocken muss. Sicherheit ist natürlich so ein Aspekt. Inwiefern ist so Sicherheit ein Konzept von Rails?
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt und wird auch immer wieder behandelt von SQL-Injections.
Ich meine, bringt das System sozusagen von sich aus irgendetwas mit, um einen zumindest vor den gassigsten Fehlern zu beschützen?
Ja, es bringt etwas mit, aber schützt einen nicht wirklich. Du kannst es umgehen, sagen wir so. Wenn du nicht darauf achtest, auf den richtigen Programmierstil, kannst du es ja auch umgehen. Aber wenn man es halt richtig macht, dann schützt es einen.
Aber was bringt es dir mit? Also wovor?
Zum Beispiel, dass du irgendwie SQL-Code in deine Suchkriterien mit aufnehmen kannst, dass es dementsprechend escapt oder überprüft, was du da übergibst.
Ohne, dass ich das jetzt explizit anstoßen muss.
Umgekehrt auch, dass du bei der Ausgabe darauf achtest, dass du da jetzt keine Werte übergeben kannst, dass es noch einmal escapt wird oder überprüft wird, was du da jetzt ausgibst.
Und das funktioniert auch gut?
Ist in Rails 3 auch default geworden? Früher musste man das explizit angeben, zum Beispiel. Mit einer Ha-Methode, hat sich das genannt.
Ach so, verstehe. Man musste schon explizit schreiben, mach mal sicher.
Ja, oder ich kenne das richtig.
Jetzt ist das Standard.
Jetzt musst du es umgekehrt sagen.
Wenn man jetzt... Worüber wir noch gar nicht so viel geredet haben, ist diese ganze Community. Bei Open Source-Sprachen und Projekten ist ja immer ganz wichtig, wie sehr man da auf eine entsprechende Community zählen kann. Manchmal ist es ja irgendwie überall, macht ja jeder. Aber es ist ja auch nicht so, dass Ruby jetzt auffallend unverbreitet wäre. Was gibt es denn so? Wie tickt denn so diese Community? Wie sind die denn so drauf?
Also ich schätze, der pragmatische Ansatz, im Prinzip sind sie, im Großteil natürlich, Leute, die sehr Wert darauf legen, guten Code zu schreiben, leserlichen Code, auch mit einem sehr pragmatischen Ansatz. Also es ist jetzt nicht nur so intellektuell abgehoben, sondern es geht auch um die wirkliche Nutzbarkeit, um die Umschätzbarkeit im zeitlichen Rahmen. Auf der anderen Seite schätze ich sehr, dass, wie du auch schon sagst, immer wieder neue Sachen ausprobiert werden, dass es, wie diese Noise-Quail-Sachen, Git zum Beispiel, ist vor allem in der Ruby-Welt sehr schnell verbreitet gewesen. Die Git-App-Leute sind ja auch...
Git-App ist eine Rails-Anwendung...
.ist eine Rails-Anwendung, beziehungsweise mit einem Erlang-Backend, aber es ist eine andere Geschichte. Sehr viel von diesen neuen Sachen kommen von Ruby-Leuten. Neue Sprachen... Ich bin aus der Java-Welt gewohnt, dass man wirklich die einzigen neuen Sprachen, die man lernt, sind die, die in den AVM laufen. Aber du lernst eigentlich kaum neue Sprachen. In Ruby ist das ganz anders. Die Leute lernen viel mehr neue Sprachen. Das ist so von den Pragmatic Programmers. Der Ansatz jedes Jahr eine neue Sprache. Zu lernen, habe ich den Eindruck, dass das...
Die Beschäftigung mit Ruby zwingt dich, andere Sprachen zu lernen?
Nicht zwingen, aber man macht es gerne. Ich kann das nicht sagen. Das ist so dieser Spirit, der dort herrscht. Das ist nicht so in seiner eigenen Suppe kochen und nicht über den Teller ranschauen.
Weil die anderen kennen das auch alle machen, sozusagen.
Wer macht das noch?
Na, die anderen Ruby-Programmierer. Also ist das so verbrannt?
Es ist das Spirit, ja genau. Man redet gerne, man beschäftigt sich gerne mit neuen Sachen.
Neophilie. Gab ja auch, also was mich sehr angesprochen hat, ging wahrscheinlich auf vielen anderen so, dass eigentlich erst mit dieser Rails-Welt war so schöne Web-Anwendungen auf einmal ein Thema. Also schon so die ersten Programmierer-Beispiele, dieses Video, was du da erwähnt hast, dieses erste Tutorial, ich baue mir meinen Blog in 5 Minuten. Alles war irgendwie eingebettet in wohlgestaltete Webseiten und sah irgendwie mal ordentlich aus, war jetzt auch nicht total überkandidelt, also jetzt auch nicht so übertrieben, aber es war einfach so eine gelassene Schickness bei allem dabei. Siehst du das eh nicht? Ist das wirklich so ein Attribut dieser Ruby-Szene? Womit hat das was zu tun?
Würde ich schon sagen. Simplicity ist ja auch so ein Grundsatz, der sehr wichtig ist. Also nicht nur der pragmatische Ansatz, sondern das... Und was hinzu kommt, dass einen gewissen Anspruch auch gelegt wird an das, was gemacht wird.
Ja, aber woher kommt das? Also ich meine, warum? Es gibt ja auch noch andere Programmierer in anderen Programmiersprachen, andere Web-Frameworks und die sind ja vielleicht auch nicht blöd. Ich habe keine Ahnung, die lernen vielleicht auch ab und zu mal eine neue Programmiersprache. Was ist da der Grund? Gibt es da irgendwie eine Erklärung dafür? Hat das was mit Japan zu tun?
Ja, mag schon sein. Nee, glaube ich nicht, weil diese Rails-Sache, die ist aus Amerika losgegangen. Das hat ja, wenn, dann was wirklich mit der Web2.0-Bedeutung zu tun.
Ja, aber es war ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen die Geburtsstätte, dieser Optik zumindest. Kannst du nicht erklären.
Nee, es sind halt dementsprechende Leute in der Community drinnen, weiß ich.
Also es ist einfach so, es ist einfach passiert, dass das so das Sammelbecken ist, der Leute, die das schätzen. Und die haben sich dann irgendwie alle so um Rails gescharrt.
Es hat auch sehr, sehr viele Möglichkeiten geboten, mit diesen ganzen Ajax-Sachen. Die waren ja fest eingebaut. Es gibt sogenannte RJS-Templates, ob die jetzt gut sind oder nicht. Aber die Ajax-Kommunikation mit dem Server, die hat von Anfang an Rails mitgebracht. Waren Möglichkeiten mit dem Auto vor Vorständigung und so weiter. Das war im Zusammenhang mit dem damals fest vertrateten Scriptaculars, das war alles fest vorgegeben, dass man so dynamisches Updates hat. Was dann heuer so schick und neu war.
Wenn man sich jetzt dem Thema Ruby und Rails dann auch einen besonderen nähern möchte, was gibt es denn so für empfohlenen Ressourcen? Was sollte man sich denn anschauen? Wie steigt man am besten ein? Bücher, Webseiten?
Gute Bücher findet man bei den Pragmatic Programmes. Dave Thomas ist hier zu nennen, der Pragmatic Ruby auch geschrieben hat. Das ist auch das Buch, mit dem ich gelernt habe. Was noch anderes?
Das sind auch die, die in PDF politizieren, ne?
Und ePAP, ja. Wie gesagt, das auch. Die haben auch ein paar Screencasts. Screencasts gibt es sowieso auch, zu erwähnen. Beep Code, die haben so ein paar Screencasts zu Ruby. Es gibt ein paar gute Blogs wie Ruby Insight, die sehr viel News über Ruby verbreiten und die Welt.
Gibt es so ein Standardwerk zum Thema?
Nein, das wäre das eigentlich, das ist ProcMatic Ruby. Was ich auch empfehlen kann, was ein bisschen mehr in die Tiefe geht, ist Ruby Way. Wie heißt der? Mel Hudson geschrieben.
Was ist jetzt auch ein Buch?
Auch ein Buch, ja.
Das ist dann schon eher philosophisch, oder wie?
Na, es ist ein Wälzer. Ich weiß gar nicht, von welchem Verlag das jetzt ist. Es ist auch viel Philosophie, wo die Grundideen von Ruby auch nochmal erläutert werden. Aber auch, wie man eben Sachen in Ruby macht. Also Alltagsgeschichten, Datumsberechnungen, String-Operationen und so weiter. Ja, und in Rails selbst gibt es auch sehr viele Screencasts, allen voran ist railscasts.com zu nennen. Die auch jetzt zu Rails 3, da sind auch schon einige erhältlich. Die sind sehr gut und die sind auch immer wieder empfehlenswert. Die sind immer nur sehr kurz, 5-10 Minuten Länge, die einzelne Aspekte beleuchten, neue Features, Plugins vorstellen, was halt gerade so gegangen und gegeben ist. Das ist ja Ryan Bates, der das macht, glaube ich, heißt der. Ich finde den sehr gut.
Also kann man sich hier einfach abonnieren als Videopodcast?
Genau.
Und dann gibt es hier alle paar Tage, ist das hier einmal die Woche. Das ist auch etwas, was ich eigentlich in dieser Ruby-Welt das erste Mal gesehen habe, dass so konsequent auch auf Screencasting gesetzt wurde, dass das erste Mal so wirklich dieses, ich erklär's dir jetzt richtig, am Bildschirm, das haben sich dann auch alle dort abgucken können. Das meiste, was ich gesehen habe, war immer auf dem Mac.
Das stimmt.
Kann das sein, dass irgendwie der Mac da besonders verbreitet ist?
Also in der Ruby-Welt, ja. Das sieht man kaum an den Rechner, gut bei Linux-Rechner.
Man sieht kaum andere Rechner?
Auf Konferenzen, ja. Das sind fast alles Macs.
Kommt das vielleicht daher, dass irgendwie alles so hübsch ist und so viel Wert auf User-Interfaces gelegt wird?
Das mag sein, ja.
Gibt es da irgendwie einen besonderen Grund, warum das so ist?
Es gibt einen Editor, mit dem die meisten arbeiten, das ist Textmade. Ruby wird ja auch seit, wie lange jetzt, mitgeliefert mit Mac. Auf Windows ist Ruby definitiv schwieriger zu handhaben. Also das war immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Wo es halt auch noch geht, natürlich gar nicht als Linux, aber die Windows-Unterstützung ist nach wie vor, würde ich nicht empfehlen, das auf Windows. Obwohl es geht mittlerweile auch schon. Textmade hat auch richtig so Bundles und Shortcuts, wo man mit Ruby-Anwendungen sehr gut arbeiten kann, wo du auch den React-Commandos losfeiern kannst, beziehungsweise Denimagrations generieren kannst, alles von einem Editor aus.
Also sozusagen auf Mac ist man dann auch gleich zu Hause mit Rails. Veranstaltungen, da gibt es auch hier, gibt es nicht sogar demnächst was in Berlin, die, wie heißt sie, Yuriko?
Die 2010er?
Ja, aber nicht in Berlin.
Man kann ja sagen, dass die 2011er in Berlin ist. Das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Ja, ja, das meinte ich damit, dass die jetzt nach Berlin kommt. Eureko.
Eureko geschrieben, genau. Die Europäische Ruby-Konferenz. Im Prinzip gibt es drei. Die japanische ist die größte. Und die amerikanische gibt's noch, die amerikanische Ruby-Konferenz. Ruby-Konf heißt die, glaube ich, auch ganz einfach.
Warst du noch mal auf irgendeiner?
Ruby-Konferenz noch nicht, ich war Rails-Konferenz auf ein paar. Die war vor der europäischen Rails-Konferenz zwei Mal in Berlin. Einmal war ich in London auf der Rails, Underground. War auch sehr spannend. Es gibt überhaupt, also das, was mir an Ruby auch sehr gefällt, es gibt einfach verdammt viele Leute, die sehr gute Talks halten können. Jim Warwick zum Beispiel, die auch schon so Dinosaurier in der Computerwelt, die seit den 60er-Jahren dabei sind und die einfach, die über sämtliche Programmiersprachen was erzählen können. Urgesteine.
Und die dann bei Ruby gelandet sind.
Die dann hauptsächlich bei Ruby gelandet sind. Die sind ja auch nicht Leute, die dann nur das machen, aber genau.
Die haben schon ein paar Jahre lang jedes Jahr eine neue Poemiersprache gelernt.
Und da kann ich sie empfehlen, auch Confreaks. Confreaks. Ja, das sind sehr viele Conference-Talks, hauptsächlich Ruby aus der Rubywelt.
Das findet sich dann alles, wie immer, in den Links zu dieser Sendung, Chaosradio Express. 163, die ich jetzt langsam mal das Ende ausrufe, Martin. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Na bitte gerne.
War auch wieder ein langer Marsch hier. Zwei Stunden Grenze locker genommen.
So war noch ein bisschen länger.
Ja, hast du noch ein paar letzte Worte zum Geleit? Was redest du so den Leuten da draußen?
Also ich denke, dass es sich auf alle Fälle lohnt, Ruby sich mal anzuschauen, weil es eine saubere Sprache ist, es auf sehr einfachen Konzepten und Prinzipien beruht und die Objekterentierung wirklich sehr gut umsetzt. Und es man auch praktisch einsetzen kann. Bei Smalltalk ist es ein bisschen schwierig. Aber ja, ich habe nach vielen Jahren Java-Programmierung in Ruby einfach richtig Spaß wieder an Programmierung gehabt. Das war so, das Hinsetzen in der Konsole, Sachen auszuprobieren. Ich habe Freude an das Erlebnis dabei empfunden. Einfach richtig Spaß wieder gehabt.
Super, so soll es ja auch sein. Spaß am Gerät. Ja, dann machen wir jetzt hier mal Schluss. Und ja, wie schon erwähnt, links an den ganzen Krampel, wie immer, habe ich schon zum Zeitpunkt, wo ihr das hört, alles ganz fleißig zusammengesucht. Und findet ihr auf chaosradioccc.de in den Links zur Sendung. Und das war's, Chaosradio Express 163.